Four three,
two,
one.
Mr. Baker,
our ancestor.
Real good.
I'm doing well.
Thanks for [inaudible].
What's going on,
man?
What are you doing in town?
Uh,
just,
uh,
was in town,
one of the,
uh,
some,
work on a sizzle reel for a show,
a new show.
Can you talk about that?
You tell people what it is?
Well,
it's actually two of them are one I can
talk about.
I can tease it a little bit.
Um,
the marketing department I guess has to
approve everything that's said.
Um,
it started out,
it's going to be on the discovery
network,
I think a science channel and it was
starting to main filming in February and
we'll should be finished by the end of
March.
So standby.
But it's started with a discussion
about,
um,
hidden budgets in the Defense
Department.
Like dark art stuff.
Yeah,
it's good.
The show's going to be called black
files.
Ah,
and the UFO type shit.
Well,
there's gonna be some of that,
a song,
but,
but from a,
you know,
not from a,
did they lie land,
did they not?
It's,
it's,
well really actually kind of tearing
into,
uh,
some of the programs that were funded
by,
you know,
hidden money,
uh,
in the Defense Department.
And do they do that?
Well,
I mean if you take like the CIA for
example,
uh,
the agency's budget is hidden inside.
It's not hidden,
but it's placed inside the Defense
Department and it's,
and it's classified piece of information
obviously.
Cause a lot of the defense department
gets a certain budget.
The CIA gets a piece of that,
but nobody's allowed to know how much or
where it's spent.
Right.
Cause obviously,
you know,
the Russians,
the Chinese,
whomever would like to know,
you know,
how much money is a sent over to the
agency so that they can get a sense of a
size,
resources,
capabilities,
that sort of thing.
Uh,
so that's where the,
the show concept started.
You know,
what,
what does that money spent on both in
the old days and now.
So it's a,
it's,
it kind of spans,
you know,
historical operations and events and
activities and special units.
And it comes up to the present time and
says,
you know,
whereas,
money being devoted now for new
technology or new programs,
new operations,
new intelligence,
gathering efforts,
whatever it might be.
So it's,
yeah,
I think it's,
it's got a lot of promise,
you know,
hopefully people tune in and find that
interesting.
Uh,
well people are always curious about
where the money goes.
Yeah,
yeah.
And you know,
I am like,
who oversees it?
Who gets,
who gets to decide like what gets spent
on what and how much money goes where.
And I do actually,
no,
I do,
that's my job.
Um,
it's a good question.
I,
you know,
that's,
I think a lot of people would be
surprised at the amount that we're
talking about it.
And it's not just,
it's not,
the intelligence community is also in
the military obviously.
Um,
can you discuss the actual numbers or
could you discuss the numbers that they
use to have a,
we'll be able to discuss the numbers
that went into past operations,
but anything that's currently
classified,
obviously it's not going to touch on.
But we've been working hard and the has
been working very hard to get excellent
access.
You know,
where possible and get cooperation where
possible.
Uh,
it's going to be a fairly immersive
effort.
So that's the benefit of the even
divulging any of this information.
Like why would they cooperate?
Why wouldn't they say,
Hey,
shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
Well,
and,
and frankly they should and they have
and they will,
but not necessarily with the agency,
but with other departments.
And certainly within the military
there's some information out there
that's accessible.
There's some ability to get them to
cooperate on,
on certain,
again,
declassified operations that just
haven't come to light.
I look a lot of Shit's been declassified
over the years that's just never been
looked at or talked about.
You know,
somebody maybe gets a wild hair up their
ass and this is says,
I want to look into this program.
And then they start peeling it back.
It's not that it's classified,
it's just nobody's ever bothered to dig
into that information,
wants it is a declassified.
So,
you know,
it's,
it's gonna be a lot of fun.
A lot of travel,
uh,
some great people working on the
program.
But,
you know,
apparently I have to,
uh,
keep it pretty much at that until the
marketing department says,
okay,
here's what you can say.
So eventually you'll be able to spill
the beans and tell us everything.
That's exactly.
So like if they're making something like
the b 52,
like if they're making a stealth bomber,
if they're making some spaceship looking
thing,
like you're talking to this insane
amount of money in research and
development and the budget of these
things and they have to keep all that
under wraps.
Yeah.
Shit.
I mean,
look,
you go back to the old days of,
um,
of the youtube program.
You have to program was developed,
it designed,
built,
maintained,
flown by the CIA all those years ago.
Right now,
that was a massive effort and a lot of
money and it was done under budget and
it was done on time.
Um,
in part because I think,
you know,
things were a little bit easier back
then and we weren't all pissing on each
other up on Capitol Hill Been,
uh,
yeah,
there's so it's,
it's,
it's programs like that that I think
will surprise people when they find out
both who was running it,
who was responsible.
Um,
and to the degree possible,
you know,
what did it cost us and you know,
who was involved and,
and to what degree did it lead to
something else that we're doing now.
So anyway,
there's,
there's a lot of,
a lot of,
you know,
threads to pull on.
I think it should be a lot of,
a lot of fun.
So there's constantly projects that are
in development that people,
other than the people that need to know,
the general public has no idea.
Like that's always the,
the,
the purse,
the people on the outside,
folks like myself,
you look at the,
he'd go,
well,
why don't we kind of,
Shit they have that they don't tell us
about like that's what you always want.
Like,
what kind of invisibility cloak,
what kind of crazy,
you know,
that would be good if dark matter
weapons,
what are they doing?
Yeah,
no it's it and it's,
it's true.
I mean you get these incredibly smart
people and it,
but it comes down to it.
It's as simple as as somebody gets an
idea,
they're sitting around a table.
It's not unlike going out with your
buddies and drinking and thinking and
I'll come with somebody comes up with
some dumb ass idea.
The next thing you know it,
it turns into a TV show or something.
But it's,
uh,
it's,
it's not unlike that.
A lot of smart guys sitting around a
table thinking,
well here's the problem.
How do we resolve it?
And the key is to do it creatively,
right?
They come up with it.
Cause if you get a bunch of engineers
around a table,
you hope that they're not at all
approaching it from the same point of
view.
Right?
It's like with an operation.
If you've got that,
you've got a high value target out there
and you've got to figure out how to get,
get access,
get to them.
You want ideas coming in from all
directions,
so you don't want it.
You don't want to squelch creativity.
And believe it or not,
I mean the Intel community and the
military,
they've been enormously creative over
the years in developing new technologies
and developing operational ideas and
methodologies.
So it's what we're trying to do is shed
some light on that.
Well,
I would imagine there's a certain
no amount of,
I don't want to use the word fun,
but that's really the right word.
Like some of it's gotta be fun to
develop this stuff and implement it and
go out and get bad guys with it and to
see your project come to fruition and
actually have a positive effect on the
world.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean if you,
it really is,
it's,
it's that simply because you know,
an operations anyway,
you know,
you,
you engage in something out there in,
in some place around the world,
wherever it may be.
And you know,
you realize as you're walking away that,
you know,
they're not a lot of people doing this
at this moment on the planet.
Right?
I mean,
so,
so the operational activity itself is
enormously entertaining as long as it
goes right.
Uh,
but it's also the buildup.
It's all that homework that gets you
there,
right?
It's,
it's like that takedown and bin Laden.
We didn't just happen to get lucky and
rock up on his doorstep right in the
bottom bud.
That was eight or nine years of fucking
hard work.
Right?
Heavy lifting,
chasing down countless bad leads and
doing enormous amounts of surveillance,
street work and tracking down assets and
doing,
I mean just it just the hard,
hard work that eventually allowed the,
you know,
all those guys from the teams to land
and do their job.
What's interesting to me too is that the
guy who was writing the book about all
this stuff and talking about,
you know,
the man who shot bin Ladin Dot guy's
persona non grata in the community.
Like you talked to the other seals,
they're like,
you don't,
you don't do that right now.
You don't do that.
You know,
you don't write books about that.
You don't talk about that and do it for
a short term gain.
You know,
you make some profit off of it,
but you lose the brothership,
you lose a,
yeah,
exactly.
You,
you're,
you're kind of on the outs in the club
and,
but I will say this,
the reason why I think,
uh,
the Horse got out of the barn on,
on that whole issue of,
of guys writing books or getting out
there and talking about specific
operations is because senior commanders
and end senior people,
right.
People that came out of the top levels
of government,
uh,
started writing their memoirs,
you know,
started revisiting history while they
were,
it was their watch and coming up with,
you know,
their explanations for history.
And I think all the guys below,
you know,
junior ranks and street level operators,
they looked at that and thought,
well,
what the fuck?
If they can do it,
why not me?
And because you've gotta set the tone
from the top.
And I think that's where it got it.
Got All know,
kind of sideways.
Plus when you have someone who you has a
crazy
story like Marcus Luttrell and it
becomes an amazing movie.
It also,
it does help the community,
right?
Because it gets a bunch of people that
are really interested in becoming a
seal.
It gets people to appreciate the,
the unbelievable sacrifice and hard work
that's involved.
Yeah.
I think that's,
I think that there is an upside,
right?
Yeah.
There's an upside to it,
but I think it's a fine balance.
Right.
What point do you go over that line?
So you're right in the sense that,
you know,
we'd see that with a w whom have with
the FBI or dea,
you know,
they got out there and put their
thumbprint on some TV shows,
right?
Because I think it kind of,
it expanded in part a awareness of,
of what they do.
I'm sure it helped their recruitment.
Um,
and so the seals are no different.
But at the same time,
uh,
you know,
you sign a piece of paper at the very
beginning that says you're going to keep
your Yap shut and,
and it's one thing to come out with from
whatever unit or whatever team or
whatever organization and say,
I'm going to write a,
I don't know about my time in,
and it's not a look at sources and
methods.
Not Look at operations.
It's not that it's more of,
you know,
this is what happened during my time.
And I think there's,
I'm not explaining it very well,
but I think there's a way you can do
that without screwing the pooch.
But I think that,
uh,
I think the seals got overexposed and I
think a lot of the guys,
uh,
resent that.
And so,
but again,
you're right there,
there was some upsides
to it.
Well,
there's upside to some of the stores,
right?
Like I've definitely these upside to
Marcus Luttrell store cause it's just so
incredible.
He question here about it.
But I think that there's also,
it's important to maintain that honor.
It's a more important to maintain that,
that bond of silence,
you know,
that you guys,
they're doing something that is probably
one of the most dangerous and one of the
most in terms of special operations,
one of the most significant in,
in,
in all of military in this country.
But yeah,
I think it's the old school guys,
the old school operators out of the
teams are definitely like,
yeah,
just,
you know,
shut your pie hole.
Don't talk about this,
the newer guys again,
because they came up in a different
time.
I mean information flows all around as
much easier and quicker than it did in
the seventies and eighties and you know,
early nineties.
But nowadays people are just used to
reading everything as soon as it happens
and creates a different mindset.
So the younger guys in there,
they don't necessarily view it the same
way.
Think about it until the Dick Marchenko
books came out.
And those were long time as long time
ago.
Yeah.
That's when I really was like,
wow,
I can't wear regular clothes.
I mean,
I think I was like probably 18 or 19
when those books were out.
And I remember thinking,
what is,
this is crazy wear long hair.
And they dress like hippies.
It just normal and go out and invade,
go ahead and fade.
And it's just,
they invading hippies,
but you know,
get,
I mean,
Marchenko was famous for wanting his
guys to get drunk together to before,
like big things.
Yeah.
Well it's that,
it's that idea of team building,
Camaraderie and however you do it.
Uh,
but there was,
there was that sense that we do it and
it's off the radar and it's not talked
about.
And we take pride in that.
But again,
I'll go back to the same thing if,
if,
uh,
if you don't,
I'm like Bob Gates,
you know,
by gates writes a book,
I'm a former director of the agency and
he's a brilliant guy,
great guy.
But he writes a book and you know,
and then you get somebody else,
maybe Mike Morrell writes a book.
And so from,
you know,
inside the CIA,
you got a lot of officers going,
well,
she had,
maybe when I get out I'll write a book
because what I'm doing is pretty damn
interesting.
And there's no laws against that.
Well,
there,
yeah,
there are [inaudible] and you know,
anybody who,
uh,
reveal sources and methods,
anybody who,
who,
uh,
who breaks their agreements in terms of
the proper handling,
which is a lifetime agreement of,
of classified information,
they're supposed to be consequences.
And sometimes there are,
and sometimes if you're senior enough,
maybe there's not.
Uh,
but uh,
yeah,
you,
you know,
you sign a piece of paper at the very
beginning.
I'll never forget that.
I read it and on it and I said,
okay,
go ahead.
There was,
it says keep your Yap Shit.
I mean I don't want to over simplify it,
but it says [inaudible] are being given
the responsibility of handling a
extremely sensitive information and
information that,
that if released can easily result in
the loss of life.
I mean it's as simple as that
essentially.
And your obligation is to shut your
mouth and not talk about sources and
methods and things that you know better
not to talk about.
And,
but I think that that kind of the drip,
drip,
right,
of the books and the things that come
out and the,
and the anonymous sources look at New
York Times can write a in a tire front
page article based on nothing but
anonymous sources nowadays never used to
happen.
Right.
You know,
editors would sit there and go,
well,
you know,
you've got to get yourself some
additional sources and that we can
discuss so people can put it in context.
Nowadays,
that's not the case.
Why do you think that is?
You know,
I think Chris,
I dunno,
we're part of it is low standards.
Yeah.
I think lower standards.
I think competition,
um,
I think the desire to get information
out there quickly because every
journalist is now,
uh,
playing beat the clock with everybody
who's got a smartphone,
right?
Fancies themselves a blogger or a
journalist on twitter or whatever.
So they're all,
they're all doing this.
And I think it's just this idea,
right?
That says,
uh,
it reminds me of me.
I had a meeting with,
uh,
with,
my company diligence for all your
information and security needs.
And it was with a major multinational
corporation and I was meeting with their
head of security and some other folks
and they do a lot of work overseas and
some very difficult places and the
competition that they face in their
sectors,
huge.
And so we went in there and we thought
this would be great.
There's a lot of things we can do for
them in terms of gathering information,
preventing them from making mistakes as
they're going into a new market.
All of these things.
And the bottom line was they said,
they looked at me and he said,
Nah,
you know what?
Competition's so fierce.
We're just going to go in.
If we make mistakes,
we'll clean it up later.
And they were willing to do that.
It's,
it's like acceptable lost credit card
fraud loss,
you know,
for mastercard or whomever.
They're willing to accept millions and
millions and millions of dollars as an
acceptable loss for,
for the cost of doing business.
And so it's a little bit like that.
I think with journalism,
they,
they're willing to just throw shit out
there and hey,
if they have to make a retraction fine.
But it compromises the way a person like
myself views the news.
I mean,
look,
I hate to quote trump,
but when he,
he's like parents that fake news term
over and over again.
You,
if you are a person who's,
or an organization is being accused of
lying,
it seems to me you should really dot
your i's and cross your t's from then on
out.
I mean,
you're being accused of lying by the
president and I think irresponsibly
accused.
I mean the way he does it,
he does it to avoid questions that make
them uncomfortable.
I mean,
and as the president,
I just don't think you should be able to
do that.
You can't point to someone from CNN and
you're fake news.
Like what does it serves 12 right?
It serves no purpose for the press that
I agree with you on a preset.
I so much of what this administration
does is a self inflicted wound.
Right.
And,
and part of it is,
is,
is that they're just crap at messaging.
Part of it is this idea that,
you know,
he just says what's on his mind and he
does,
right.
It's almost like he's got tourettes,
but I think he views it as a strength.
He views it as a reason why he got
elected.
And a lot of people out there think,
yeah,
that's his,
his base.
You know,
the people that are really behind them
no matter what.
I think they view it as part of his
charm as well.
And the problem is he does release
classified information sometimes.
Yeah.
We've had that problem with,
uh,
several administrations.
They just don't know what to not say.
Well,
I think part of it again is,
uh,
yeah,
there's,
there's a,
a laxness that's developed over the
years and I don't know why.
Right?
Because,
you know,
I mean,
I think about all the various security
issues we face.
And look,
we've been at war for 17 years,
right?
Since nine 11 and all these things that
have been happening to us,
you would think that we'd be pretty
buttoned up.
But now every administration has had its
moment where it's let slip.
And whether it was the press secretary
of whether it was somebody rushing to
the podium,
it was somebody on Capitol Hill.
I mean,
they're famous for it up there,
you know,
congressmen and congresswomen or
senators all in the,
in,
in a rush to get in front of the camera
to talk about something and then,
you know,
shit happens.
Thanks.
Get out that they shouldn't.
So I think it's,
it all kind of contributes to this
mentality that we started off talking
about with,
with the seals were,
you know,
why are we in this point where people
are writing books and maybe getting
outside the box?
And I think it's just because,
yeah,
it's this constant drip and lowering of
standards like you mentioned,
I think,
and it's a,
I don't think we walk that dog bag.
I don't,
you know,
it just the way it is now,
you're not in the agency anymore,
but I'm sure you stay tight with people
that are still there.
What,
what is the attitude now with this
administration?
Like what they're doing with like the
way he attacks the FBI and way,
like,
it just seems,
it seems so reckless.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's a unusual,
I mean that,
look,
I,
there's,
here's the way I feel,
but I didn't vote for,
for president.
I didn't vote for Hillary Clinton.
I think either of them than the best we
could do when a country of over 300
million people,
and we've talked about this before,
that it was you or I that did what
Hillary did.
We'd be in jail.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And so,
um,
but as far as you know,
what the,
the,
the current mood inside the agency as,
I mean,
if you talk to some former folks,
they,
you know,
they'll say,
ah,
morale is awful.
It was terrible.
And then,
you know,
they just,
hating life because there's not,
I don't find that,
I find that,
um,
the,
frankly they're just more focused on
operational concerns and priorities and
tasking than anything else.
Everybody's got a personal opinion.
Right.
But I do think that the agency has
proven itself over the years at being
better at pushing that down and
understanding.
And in part because it's a smaller
organization,
right then most of them then almost all
of them and,
but he's,
he's not,
he doesn't go after the CIA.
Right.
It's only going after the FBI.
He's got the FBI.
I mean,
he's,
you know,
he's questioned,
he's done.
He's done some things in terms of
questioning CIA analysis and,
uh,
and,
you know,
some of the advice and guidance that
they provided.
But that again,
you sort of look at and go,
hey,
look,
we're feeding this into the NSC,
the National Security Council.
You guys,
you know,
that's,
that's an editorial process.
At that point,
you guys are going to have to make your
decisions.
Um,
uh,
you know,
have,
people are going to say,
I'm just saying this because I'm
subjective and I,
you know,
I'm providing top cover for the agency,
but for the most part,
they just focus on getting shit done.
And we also have the benefit of big
focused overseas.
So we're not like the bureau is,
you know,
and it's a domestic organization,
right?
So they,
you know,
they're drawn in,
the agency's got the advantage of,
look,
we're having to deal with crap over
there and not here.
So now,
what did you think when he said that
we're going to pull out of Syria?
Well,
first of all,
yeah,
they just had that,
uh,
we've,
we've lost some servicemen up in
northern Syria today.
Um,
today as a result of a bombing up there.
Yeah,
Isis has taken credit for it.
So there,
there was a,
uh,
patrol and we,
and we've got roughly 2000 personnel in
Syria.
And for the most part,
what are they doing there where they're
providing a guidance training.
Um,
they're assisting with targeting,
uh,
and because the,
the air power is incredibly important
over there right now.
And so we are,
uh,
our personnel are,
very much involved in selection of
identification of targets,
uh,
for the air campaign.
And,
um,
so we have these 2000 troops here.
President says he's going to withdraw
and then then some of the members of
administration started walking that dog
back,
right.
And saying,
man,
I know it may not happen right away,
but yeah,
they just,
there was just a,
a routine patrol.
Uh,
if there this never really such thing as
a routine patrol,
but there's a patrol,
um,
and it got hit.
Uh,
the military is not releasing a lot of
details because they haven't finished
notifying next to kin,
but,
um,
numbers so far indicate possibly for
service,
um,
uh,
lost.
Um,
and that's going to refocus,
I think Congress and hopefully the White
House on what the hell is going on.
The problem I've got with it is in terms
of withdrawing,
look,
we could stay there forever and not
accomplish the task,
right?
If the task is to finally defeat
whatever that means,
uh,
radical Islamic jihadists,
Isis,
uh,
that shit's never going to happen.
Not In our lifetimes.
We're not going to get rid of that
mentality that,
that ideology,
uh,
the sort of what seems to be sometimes a
bottomless well of recruits that they
can draw on their ability to morph into
something else as al Qaeda did,
um,
over,
depending on how successful we are in a
campaign against them,
they're like,
you know,
again,
it's,
you know,
it's like,
step on roaches over here and they pop
up over here.
So I think it's the,
the,
the biggest problem I've got is,
is that if we leave,
we're not,
we're not.
Um,
you know,
it's not like we're engaged in
firefights everyday with isis over
there.
Right.
We've left that to our allies and our
allies in most part up there in the
north of Syria are the Kurds.
The Kurds have been our allies in one
way or another in that part of the world
for a long time now.
And it played a very important role and
we have not been particularly honorable
over the,
over the years in terms of how sometimes
we deal with them.
If we walk out,
if we leave,
then uh,
Irwin,
you know,
the head of Turkey,
I guarantee you we'll be in there in
short order to kill as many of them as
possible because that's just what the
Turkish authorities are going to do.
They honestly,
uh,
that they couldn't be happier with the
announcement that we're going to leave
because that opens the door for them to
think,
go in there and from their perspective,
stamp out the Kurdish alliance that have
been our allies.
We're the only thing our presence at
small presence,
you know,
not minimizing it,
but it,
you know,
2000 troops has been what's prevented
them from doing that.
So that's,
that's the number one issue I've got.
The other is,
I have no idea why any president or vice
president or anybody in the government
ever,
not this is administration or any
administration ever thinks it's a,
it's a good idea to say we've defeated
the enemy.
Uh,
when we're talking about radical Islam,
we've seen it over and over again from
previous administration,
from the Bush administration.
Every time they say,
you know,
we were,
we've done it,
mission accomplished,
mission accomplished though we'd be,
we'd beaten al Qaeda,
we beat nicest.
That's it.
There's no upside to saying that.
Shut the fuck up.
Stop saying things like that.
It's again,
it's a self inflicted wound at the,
because now what's happening in the
media is not focused on the fact that
we've lost servicemen.
They're focused on,
well,
just,
uh,
just the other day the president said,
we defeated Isis and the vice president
today said the same thing.
Now look what's happened.
There's no benefit to saying that.
And,
and,
and it's not going to happen anyway.
So the goal of being over there is to
assist our allies,
but also to make sure that these radical
factions don't become more powerful.
And then eventually affect us and attack
us.
And so we can keep an eye on what
they're planning,
what they're doing.
Is that,
is that an accurate
yeah,
it is.
It,
it,
it's,
it's exactly it.
I mean,
if you look at
the reason we went into Afghanistan,
right?
If we go back all those years,
Holy Shit.
Uh,
and that was because the Taliban
allowed,
um,
al Qaeda to establish a beachhead in
there for training and for
communications and for finance and for
plotting and planning attacks outside of
Afghanistan against us and our allies.
That's why we went in there,
aside from just seeking revenge,
obviously was to route that out.
We then stayed,
you know,
thinking somehow we were going to turn
the tide of history and create some
pseudo federal democracy.
Right?
So that didn't,
that didn't work.
But the reason now for being in Syria is
yes,
we,
we have done a very solid job of beating
back isis,
removing their territory and degrading
their ability to operate.
But we haven't stamped them out.
We haven't defeated them yet.
They're still there.
And so we've been providing the support
and the,
again in the form of,
uh,
weapons,
hardware,
gear of resources,
training,
and most importantly a comp,
uh,
combat air operations,
air assaults.
And,
um,
that's been critically important.
If we leave,
I have no doubt that isis will find some
way to rejuvenate,
maybe not in its current form,
but,
and maybe not in the same exact
locations,
but they don't work.
Cause that's what they do.
They just,
they just find a way to adapt.
And we already know what's happened in
the past when we,
when we left Iraq,
we saw what happened with the rise of
Isis.
So,
you know,
I do I want to stay there forever.
Absolutely not.
But both sides can make a valid
argument.
One for staying,
one for leaving my,
I think the best argument for staying in
the,
in it certainly is short and midterm,
is to ensure that ertl on doesn't
slaughter a bunch of Kurtz who have been
working with us.
Uh,
honorably.
Um,
you know,
I don't know how else to say that.
So we'll see what happens.
I,
the
best argument to stay is to protect the
people that helped us to protect our
allies.
Yeah.
So it's not in our best interest is in
the best interest of our commitment and
agreement with them.
Well,
is it in our national security interests
do to stay in Syria,
for example?
Right.
There was this,
that has so many levels to this thing,
and I'm sure right now everybody's
listening going off.
Fuck Sake.
He's not going to disappear down a
rabbit hole.
But,
but uh,
yes,
I am.
Uh,
eh.
For a while there,
there was this,
this,
this idea,
this was ridiculous pie in the sky
thought that we were going to get the
Russians out of Syria,
that we're going to fucking happen.
Russian said the only port for their
Black Sea fleet as in Syria,
you know,
w w they've been there for decades and
decades along with Iran.
We're net,
it's not gonna happen unless we want to
go to war with Russia to kick them out
of Syria.
That's not in our best interest.
So is it in our national security
interest to keep troops there to fight
and try to minimize Russian involvement
in Syria?
I don't think so because we're not going
to shift them off that dime without
going directly at them.
Right.
It's in their best interest to stay and
every nation accidents own best
interest.
Are we going to shift Iran?
Are we going to keep Iran from forming
too late for that?
They've already got a beachhead there
that they're not going to give up.
And so you've got to set those issues
aside and say,
well,
what the hell are we doing there?
Oh we,
oh we there simply because we have to,
you know,
finish the fight against Isis.
Well,
you know,
at some point you gotta say,
I guess I wouldn't say that we've,
we're,
we've defeated them,
but I think we would say,
yeah,
we've degraded them sufficiently that we
can,
we can now operate from elsewhere and
then we can operate from forward basis
and in other locations where we're
currently based.
Great.
But again,
I keep coming back to the same thing
that,
you know,
we've,
we've worked with the Kurds.
Is this in our national security
interest?
Well,
no,
I guess it's not,
but there's something that tells me it's
the right thing to do and maybe
sometimes that's enough,
you know,
that we should,
we should not let [inaudible] have his
way
and also longterm wouldn't it be in our
best interest to honor our commitment
and make sure that we protect our allies
so that in the future other allies would
be more willing to cooperate with us
because they understand that once we're
committed,
we're fully committed and we stay and we
stand for something.
Yeah.
So what's the benefit of getting out?
Like the people that see,
think we should get out?
Like when trump said he wanted to pull
out,
like what's his thinking
runs particularly deep?
I think it just,
I think it's,
you know,
uh,
during the campaign he talked about,
you know,
stopping the endless wars.
That's very popular concept right now.
Again,
nobody wants to,
I mean,
what the hell?
and so it will be interesting to see,
you know,
what today's sad event does up on
Capitol Hill,
you know,
do they,
do they rethink their,
the,
the withdrawal or do they accelerate it?
Well,
like when they had the buildup in Iraq
and it was highly criticized but then it
was very effective,
like it did do what they intended it to
do.
Right.
And it did knock back the enemy.
If they decided to ramp it up worldwide,
would that be a solution to any of this
or is the opposite,
is it better to actually ramp up our
defenses domestically and just stay the
fuck away from all of these people?
Yeah.
Um,
well eventually you can only,
I mean you can only do so much I think
on the domestic front.
Um,
and then,
uh,
you know,
if,
if they gained sufficient ability and
strength,
we've seen that from past attacks,
I think then,
then they'll come after you,
they'll come after us.
And that's just the way I suppose that's
going to work.
But I don't disagree with the notion
because it is hard pressed.
I look,
I wouldn't have stayed in Afghanistan.
Frankly,
I don't care whether they've increased
their literacy rate by 2% are built
another road or whatever.
It doesn't matter.
They don't,
they don't know what the hell we're
trying to sell them.
Right.
So I don't,
uh,
I'm not against the notion of getting
out,
but this one's a tough one.
I guess that's what I'm saying is,
is that the Syria issue is,
I'm real conflicted on because of the
Kurds and what they've done on our
behalf in the past and how they've
suffered and knowing,
uh,
going years and years back,
you know,
having dealt with that issue,
uh,
two and a half decades ago,
a long time ago with the Turks and the
Kurds,
knowing how vicious that could be a,
and I don't trust her to want as far as
I could throw him on a window.
So,
you know,
I think there's a problem there that we
need to,
we need to make sure we've talked
through thoroughly before we just say,
sure,
let's get them out of there.
You know,
what the hell,
you know,
we shouldn't have them there.
And we shouldn't be there,
but like everything else,
so it's,
it's,
it's complicated.
You would like to think that what
they're having conversations like this
up on Capitol Hill,
you know,
between the,
the parties,
uh,
Republicans or the Dems,
but I don't think they are,
that's what was concerning me.
What concerns me is,
especially a guy like trump,
if trump is the guy who was decided
we're going to pull out a Syria,
like,
wow,
how does he have enough time to
carefully consider that as well as all
the other things that are on his plate.
And when someone runs for president,
save someone's campaigning and they say,
you know what,
I support a non interventional as
foreign policy.
I'm going to get us out of these,
these wars.
I'm going to get there doing this based
on a limited amount of information.
Like it's not like the CIA or the FBI or
anybody briefs them as they're running
for president.
They don't have clearance.
Right,
right,
right.
Until you become the party nominee,
When you're the party nominee,
then do you get a discussion?
Get you get some access,
right.
It's not your stone out the president.
Right.
But you are given some ability to get a
more intensive briefings.
Yeah.
But it's not,
it's not to the degree that the
president,
so someone like Hillary,
she was already secretary of State
Charlie.
She already knew pretty much
these things.
Yeah.
She had,
yeah.
She,
she was very switched on,
very informed.
She would just an awful candidate.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Um,
I,
you know,
so I think that um,
look,
I,
there's certain things that this
administration is doing foreign policy
wise that I think are good.
It makes sense.
Um,
there were other things that I think,
you know,
you just leave you scratching your head.
Um,
but that's like every administration.
I guess my point is we've gotten away
from that ability,
right.
I have conversations,
I go out to dinner with folks that,
you know,
on the,
on the hard left and when you talk to
them,
they fully believe,
fully believe that president trump is a
Russian puppet,
a wedding asset of Putin who is just
doing Putin's bidding.
And they honestly honestly believe that
and nothing is going to shift them off
that position too.
When you have a,
you know,
that sort of frame of reference,
you don't have the ability to look at
anything rationally and say,
yeah,
okay,
I like this policy related to China.
It's about time we call them out and say
that you obviously have not been a fair
trading partner.
That's something that every
administration has agreed to but has
never done anything about.
So you would think that everybody will
be able to say,
hmm,
makes sense.
Yeah,
I like it.
Everybody should be able to say the
immigration,
you know,
system here in the,
in the states is somewhat dysfunctional.
It needs fixing.
Everybody's talked about that and yet
they can't do it because they've got
this,
this mindset that,
that that prevents them from having any
sort of conversation,
any sort of rational discussion that
could lead to some compromise that could
then advance the ball and make this
government more functional.
So,
so where we're at right now is,
uh,
today is day,
what are the shutdown?
26th I think that would just be so
800,000 American workers that work for
the government are not getting paid.
So there are a month out many of these
people paycheck to paycheck.
They don't have medical necessities,
they don't have food.
People are happening to our rationale
off their,
their,
their insulin.
If they're diabetic.
I mean I'm hearing these horror horror
stories,
the lines at the airport or around the
fucking block.
It's,
it's chaos.
And it seems like there's no end in
sight.
And it seems like trump has just content
to,
to sell,
hold this position.
Well,
I think both sides are content to hold
their position.
That seems fucking crazy to me.
It is crazy.
It's absolutely crazy.
If you think about it.
And it's not just 800,000 I don't know
the exact numbers,
but think about all the,
the contractors,
I think when all the government
contractors,
right,
I stay in,
I don't think they're good
paid.
Yeah.
Right.
And so this has,
and,
and you know,
the administration has admitted that,
look,
we initially underestimated the impact
of,
of a longer term shutdown.
And so they understand that.
And the Democrats,
you know,
talk about it every minute about how
this is a terrible crisis.
And so you would think that if both
sides feel that way,
uh,
then get something done and looked at
the Democrats that they've approved in
the past,
recent past,
many of these Democrats voted for
fencing barriers,
whatever you want to call it.
Yeah.
But we're lost in semantics and because
the president's so hated by this,
you know,
this,
this group that,
you know,
they've seized on this term wall.
If he had started his campaign by saying
we need to improve our border security
and,
uh,
find fixes to an immigration system that
is both fair and secure and efficient.
If he had gone with that,
it's a word he bumper sticker.
But if he had gone with that and we'd
have a different conversation right now,
we would,
but maybe would have a different
president as well.
Yeah.
That's okay.
That's a good point.
There's something about that build that
wall that's like the dopes.
We're like,
Whoa,
get it John.
It's a wall.
Still simple.
Build a wall.
Oh yeah.
Look her castle build a wall.
It seems so,
uh,
it's,
it's such a visual.
No,
you're right.
That's,
and that's,
you know,
that's where I miss out.
I,
I'm way off on the,
in terms of being clever about politics,
but I,
well,
how to rope in rubes.
Yeah,
I should,
I should get better at that.
But he's got that down boy.
I didn't even know the people that voted
for him.
The people that are like real mag
supporters,
I didn't even know they existed in the
numbers.
They exist.
It's like he uncovered a rock.
Like you flipped a rock over and there
was an ant colony of rubes in there.
And just the sheer numbers,
it's like,
whoa,
there's the top patio.
Right.
It's a mixed bag.
You've got a lot of people very,
you know,
cause it's,
I,
I don't buy the idea that it's all just
a bunch of crackers or a bunch of
idiots.
There's a,
it's a,
it's a real range of people.
There's,
there's that group of people that were
just tired of being told they're idiots
and they came out in force.
Right.
You can't tell,
you can't talk down to people.
This is for the Democrats.
You can't keep talking down to people
and expect at some point,
then I can punch in the nose.
That's right.
Well,
they're still doing that now.
And there's still a there,
there,
there was some congressmen recently that
was talked about all the people that
supported trump and he was talking about
them all being losers and alcoholics and
illiterate.
And I'm like,
man,
you're talking about half the country,
right?
No lesson learned,
No,
absolutely.
No self awareness.
And uh,
and that's,
you know,
that's the story of,
of,
you know,
every election I think going forward is,
you've,
you've got the urban centers and you've
got everybody else and everybody else
feels as if they're getting kicked in
the ass.
And so I,
but,
but yeah,
at the same time,
you think,
look,
we should be able to do better.
We should.
I,
again,
certain policies that they've got great,
but every day,
another tweet that seems a little
dysfunctional every day,
you know,
some misstep every day,
some self inflicted wound,
um,
shouldn't happen.
Not in a country.
This size,
not,
not where we've got this much talent and
skill and capability.
So I don't know what 20 is going to
bring,
but it's,
we got to,
we're in for a hell of a ride between,
um,
you know,
look at all the shit that's happening.
Yeah.
This seems like it might be one of the
bigger moves on the chessboard though.
This government shutdown,
like how this gets resolved one way or
another and who comes out,
at least the,
the visual is the optics are that
they're the winner.
Yeah.
That's,
it seems very critical because if the
Democrats win and somehow or another he
abandons his idea for a wall,
abandons the billions of dollars that
he's been asking for for this wall that
gives them momentum.
We kicked his ass with that wall and
we're going to kick his ass and 20,
exactly what they're thinking.
That is,
that is exactly what they're discussing
in the war room when Nancy Pelosi keeps
them all in lockstep and she's done a
good job so far of keeping the dams in
line.
Um,
and that's why they wanted her back in,
at least the old guard wanted it back in
because that's what she does.
Well,
aside from fundraising,
so I,
you know,
I have a feeling that,
look,
he's asking for whatever,
five point $7 billion in the scheme of
things.
That's a drop in the bucket and Schumer
and Pelosi in a wide variety of other
people,
including the previous president and all
voted in the past for additional funding
for border security,
including fencing and barriers.
But they aren't,
they're not going to budge off of this.
So what the hell does that mean?
Does that mean he's,
he's being pushed into a corner where he
has no option but to declare a national
emergency and use funds elsewhere so
that he can say,
I finally got it done and looked at
demos,
didn't do anything.
Uh,
who knows?
But you're,
I think you're absolutely right.
Whoever's perceived as the winner out of
this,
you know,
ridiculous situation.
Uh,
yeah,
they're going to beat that drum all the
way to 2020.
One of the things they've been saying
too about the wall is that they want to
keep drugs from coming in,
uh,
illegal drugs.
But from this El Chapo trial,
we're learning how the biggest drug
dealer in Mexico got his drugs and they
didn't use,
they didn't get it through the wall.
They brought it in through mostly boats.
Yeah.
It's usually not,
um,
just meals,
you know,
individuals carton into cross some,
broken part of the,
of the border.
They brought it
cars in hidden compartments.
They brought it in through boats.
I mean,
they're,
you know,
they basically have some people spilling
the beans as to how the exact operation
was,
was functional and it didn't seem to
involve people carrying it over the
border on backpack.
Now when it goes months,
uh,
El Chapo is a lieutenants,
is a,
as a cooperating witness and he's now,
he's now claiming that the former
president of Mexico and UNESCO was given
$100 million at the outset of his term,
I think it was 2012 when he started as
president.
So when he was president lacked,
he'd already won.
But he had his wedding to take the seat.
According to this,
this Colombian trafficker who was
working with Guzman with chapel,
a pinion eto reached out to him,
possibly there was campaign manager.
However,
the story goes,
my friend and he,
and he asked for 250 million and chapel,
you know,
came back with a negotiated position.
It says 100 million,
which was then according to this,
again,
the guy's a Colombian trafficker.
It,
you know,
how legitimate is he,
uh,
then,
you know,
the money was transferred to opinion at
tdot.
Uh,
and you know,
opinion at all.
Those people are saying,
that's ridiculous.
Look,
we were the ones who tracked him down,
you know,
even though we escaped,
48 times or whatever,
he escaped.
And,
uh,
but there's always been this,
this talk about how chopos arrests were
orchestrated,
right?
But,
and that,
so that the,
the,
the military,
the police were involved somehow that
there was a coordinated effort.
And,
uh,
there's always been that underlying
rumor,
you know,
is it possible anything's possible.
But if he did get $100 million,
you would think El Chapo would be free.
Jesus Christ if $100 million and get
your free.
Right.
Yeah,
I know.
And you would,
yeah.
You would assume that,
you know,
what's the upside for Chapo to,
to not talk about it now.
Right.
Um,
but uh,
you know,
who knows?
It's,
it's a precedent to mean where's he
doesn't have tax returns.
They could look at,
it seems like a lot of cash.
Hey,
moved it.
Just moved it off shore immediately.
Apparently it was according to this
witness or to this cooperating witness,
the money was delivered.
Uh,
this may be the part of the story that
doesn't hold up.
It was delivered to his campaign plane
or something in his campaign manager
took control of it and then they whisked
it away.
What are they going to know?
Hole in the ground somewhere.
It takes out a little at a time.
Keep everybody on that hush hush.
I was looking at that.
What's that crazy lady's name?
Laura loomer,
the lady Nancy Pelosi's fence.
She,
uh,
camped out on her,
her yard.
You know what made me think like,
how fucks Nancy Pelosi,
you own that house.
Where's she getting all that cash?
Yeah.
What's her net worth now?
A couple of hundred million.
Really?
I forget if I mean to do what she in
business.
She came from a hardcore political
family and Baltimore I think,
and there's so much dirty money she's
been doing.
She's
100 million.
I was waiting on us.
She's worth 100 million estimated,
but that's like,
I don't know if it's a one of those
online at work.
Where does she get her money from?
Oh,
you gotta be Shit.
You know what?
Maybe she's good at.
Just scrounge Jamie keeping her a per
diem.
Yeah,
that's
what I mean.
What is the,
what's her national set annual salary?
Well,
she just started getting it for this
job.
Wouldn't it be a 450 grams?
Wow.
No,
no,
that's,
that's the net worth of five.
Which net worth or a median net worth
now?
This person's okay.
Congress person.
So it can't be anything higher than an
sis something.
So it's probably not more than a hundred
it's all her good work.
She did with the Clinton Foundation.
Oh,
speaker of the house gets (220) 300-0200
grand.
She's worth $100 million.
What in the holy fuck is that?
How has that,
and she does have a big wall around it.
Please.
Yeah.
Not enough to keep.
Laura loomer
is not an athlete.
Steve's right over that son of a mess.
It's not like she's a park core athlete.
Fuck.
Did she get over that?
I show up with some,
uh,
illegals,
illegal immigrants or whatever,
undocumented workers,
whatever issues.
She changed herself to twitter.
I know she did that to that broad.
That's right.
She's going hard for attention.
It's,
it's very interesting when these,
uh,
these people just try so hard to make it
into the news.
Well,
they're looking for a contributor slot.
They're looking for on one network or
another.
I think that's what they're doing.
You have to nowadays,
I think that that,
I think,
at least my theory is anyway,
if you want to be a paid contributor for
a network,
no,
it doesn't matter which network.
You'll got to stake out a position.
Uh,
that involves some crazy,
right?
You've got to be like you how they get
be all in for president trump or you
gotta be all out if you,
if you live in the center,
that ain't happening.
Right?
Nobody wants to hear from anybody in the
middle because that Shit's not picking
up the ratings at all.
So no one wants reasonable middle right
now?
No.
The only time that I think reasonable,
middle,
whatever workout as if the two ends are
so fucked up and they're fighting so
hard on the opposite ends.
Like someone's like,
God,
surely it's got to be a reasonable
middle and then someone comes along.
It's almost like the people gotta be
screaming for it,
but right now it doesn't seem like
people are screaming for no sensible
centrist position.
It's like a world war one trench
warfare,
right.
I mean that's,
that's the way it is with the government
shut down right now and I'll close.
He's sitting over here in the mud and
president trump's sitting over here in
the mud and nobody's given any ground
and they're just,
they're just occasionally taking a shot
at each other.
Throwing a hand grenade and nobody is
making any,
any movement.
So I,
you know,
again,
how do they shut the,
or how do they stop the shutdown?
You can't,
if you're not talking,
if you're not,
if there's,
if there's no effort,
it's not going to happen.
So everybody's looking at this right now
and thinking,
you know,
where's it go?
It's affecting the markets.
It makes us look like morons.
Uh,
I mean,
not that others aren't.
look at,
look at Britain,
right?
With the brexit thing.
Look at France with the yellow vests.
Look at the,
you know,
Germany's having a tissue.
So,
Eh,
you know,
everybody's having some,
some,
some problems,
but you know,
we didn't need to add to the noise.
John Stossel had an interesting video
that he put out where he's saying,
what this does actually highlight is
that there's a lot of things that the
government does.
It really should probably be privatized
and we wouldn't have these issues.
Does that,
I mean,
it kind of made sense to me,
but I don't know a lot.
Yeah,
no,
I,
I'm,
I'm a small government person.
At the end of the day,
I think,
you know,
there's certain things that we need to
rely on the government for a,
and one of them would be of course,
national security,
terrific.
You know,
collection of federal taxes.
Okay,
fine that day they're going to do that
regardless.
Uh,
but otherwise just stand on my kitchen.
Right,
right.
Don't,
don't,
you know,
and so,
and that's why I've always been
surprised me mean the Republican's
problem I got with them is,
you know,
you can't sit around and argue for small
government and then try to tell people
what to do with their bodies or who can
get married and who can't get married.
Who the fuck cares?
I right.
Just don't,
don't hurt people.
Be a good person.
Get on with it.
I don't need to celebrate your
lifestyle,
but just do it.
I really don't care.
I don't expect you to care about my
lifestyle.
I don't care about yours.
But the Republicans have always stuck
their nose in this and you can't,
you can't make that argument for,
for wanting small government.
And if you just want to step into
people's bedrooms all the time,
it doesn't make any sense.
And I think the only reason why they do
it is because it gets people excited
that they get to run to,
to,
to vote for them.
I think when they take these positions,
it's not like these are really having an
effect on their lives or at some moral
stand that they must take because God
wants them to do it.
I think they do it because they think
that it's going to get,
it's going to shift the pole one way or
another.
Yeah.
And it's going to get people excited
about them possibly making some sort of
a difference that they feel is going to
significantly affect their position.
But do you ever get to the point,
I mean,
I don't know whether that's going to
happen,
but you would think that you've got the
people on the hard right and the hard
left,
they're not going to shift.
Right.
That's not going to happen.
You're not going to move those people.
So like everybody always talks about
decisions are made by that small group
in the center.
So at what point did the group in the
center find it?
Put their hands up and go,
you guys are all fucked up.
Right.
How about a third party that's
legitimate,
not a libertarian party because that's
right.
It hasn't been working out.
Um,
but something that creates a little bit
of a different dynamic and we're never
going to get term limits.
So that's,
you know,
tilting at windmills,
but maybe,
you know,
maybe we get that multiparty thing go on
that.
Ha again.
Okay.
It's pie in the sky.
Well,
crap.
Closest we ever got to it was Ross
Perot,
right?
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
And he was,
so,
it was a piece of work,
but when he took out a whole,
he took a block of time,
I believe it was a half an hour on
national television.
He bought the time to explain how you're
getting fucked.
Yeah.
And explained taxes and explain all
these different things.
And people are like,
wait,
what?
That's how it works.
It's good tv.
If you can go back and find it.
It's,
it's Ross Perot was good tv.
I'll show you what I'm doing here.
Well.
Yeah,
I see.
That's all that's all fucked up.
And here's where again,
fuck yeah.
A shit.
Hey,
we talked about,
remember the last time we talked about
Huawei?
Yes.
And it hasn't gone away.
No,
it hasn't gotten the way sees good.
Someone just got arrested yesterday.
Two people,
two people.
Uh,
so,
uh,
so backstory,
fascinating.
This is fascinating.
So I,
this is,
this is an area I could definitely
disappear down to Chinese espionage,
right?
They go on forever.
Uh,
once again I say,
you know,
I talk about are there certain things
that the current administration is doing
that I like?
One of them is the way that they're
dealing with China right now.
And yes,
the trade issue is buffeting the market
somewhat and causing some instability.
But again,
previous administration,
the Bush administration clinic,
lots of,
lots of prep from former presidents.
They all acknowledged that China pub
privately was not a fair trading
partner.
This administration's at least trying to
call them out and calling them out on
the,
on the,
in the cyber issue too,
uh,
on their,
on their theft of intellectual property.
So anyway,
wowway,
um,
supposedly owned by the founder and
however many employees,
you know,
I think Huawei is by the way,
uh,
the number one telecommunications
equipment manufacturer in the world.
And they're the number two seller of
smartphones,
right?
They,
they're,
they're a bigger seller of smartphones
and apple.
So at Samsung,
Huawei,
apple,
uh,
for this.
And so supposedly the company's owned by
the founder and his daughter is the
chief operating officer,
chief financial officer,
one of those.
She was arrested up in Canada,
um,
and she was arrested at the request of
the u s she's up there on bail right
now,
waiting extradition hearing.
And the reason was because supposedly
she lied about wally's dealings with
Iran and they were busting sanctions by
dealing and providing certain types of
equipment to Iran.
Now,
uh,
this,
this past week we've had a hallway
employee who's now been fired by Huawei
in Poland,
uh,
arrested for espionage.
And along with him is a member of the
Polish intelligence service,
right.
Who,
uh,
retired now and was now working for a
French telecommunications company,
but was arrested also for a espionage
related to a and unrelated to this
individual who up until just recently it
was working for wallet,
Huawei Claims Innocence and says,
well,
we have no idea.
And the founder just came out and gave
this big speech and said,
I would never let the Chinese
authorities tell me what to do.
And now we'd certainly never spy on
anybody using quallies capabilities and
technology.
And people are probably thinking,
what the fuck are you talking about?
This for?
A Huawei embeds their telecommunications
equipment throughout the world,
right?
So it's in,
uh,
our allies,
military operations,
which then are connected to ours,
right.
In terms of communications and transfer
of intelligence and information.
Um,
they're everywhere.
And they chose Poland.
They've been in Poland for about 10
years.
Poland is a very important NATO ally.
So I,
I'm,
I'm taking a long time,
I realized to explain this,
but what I'm trying to say is nothing
happens by happenstance,
right?
The Chinese don't operate that way.
So the Chinese authorities sometime ago,
years ago,
looked at it and went,
yeah,
this makes sense,
right?
We've got Huawei,
which by the way,
the founder is a former military,
uh,
people's Liberation Army engineer.
Um,
he,
um,
they,
they looked at this and they thought
Poland,
uh,
that would be a good beachhead for us,
right?
Because there are a key element of NATO,
so let's go to Poland.
So they started a burrowing into Poland
striking deals and you know,
they're basically the most important
foreign relationship now a corporation
inside a Poland and they're fully
embedded and they've had access to at
this point to NATO communications.
And now the arrest of these two
individuals.
And people will still,
despite this and despite their past,
despite their,
their,
their theft of information from
everybody from us steel to,
uh,
to Alcoa,
to Lockheed Martin to dupont,
all the times that they've been stealing
information,
people will still go wide.
You know,
I don't,
I don't believe it.
that doesn't make any sense.
I don't see why the Chinese would act
that way.
And I don't see why we're being so harsh
on them.
You know,
this tariff thing is a bad idea.
My point being,
you got to call them out.
They're not going to necessarily change
their behavior,
but you got to raise public awareness,
make uh,
our allies understanding where that's
what we're doing right now.
We're saying you've gotta,
you've gotta put the brakes on this,
build a firewall,
use other companies,
telecommunications equipment.
Because you know,
the fact that we're tied in with our
allies,
with Poland and with Canada and you
know,
that gives them access to us.
So for someone on the outside,
look myself was trying to look at this.
And you,
you say that while stealing stuff like
stealing stuff from us steel,
how are they doing that?
Well,
they,
I mean the u s steel,
admittedly that was,
that was a pla,
that was the People's Liberation Army,
a third department operation against
dupont and,
and also against us steel and others.
So that was a little bit different.
I,
I conflated the two.
But Huawei,
one of the things that they do is by
having access,
uh,
and,
and embedding their equipment in your
communications infrastructure,
that gives them the ability then to,
uh,
in,
in a simple way to tap in,
right?
It's just a package intercept
information,
right?
Basically.
So you have communication.
So imagine we're trading information
through NATO,
uh,
channels,
right?
All they need is that one in,
That's it.
It's like everything else.
It's like fishing,
right?
It's just like,
you know,
when,
when hackers just an individual hacker
sitting in somebody's basement,
you know,
he just needs that one avenue.
He needs to get one s.
It's just,
just click on that email that gives me
the pathway in.
So when,
when Huawei is able to embed their
technology into Polish communications,
and we're now connected because of our
NATO alliance,
that gives them access to us,
France,
whomever.
And you know,
it's not as if it just happened.
It's not as if Huawei from a business
perspective says,
you know,
I bet we could sell some of our
equipment and Poland.
Wouldn't that be good?
The guy who was arrested,
the Huawei person who was arrested was
responsible for,
uh,
the provision of telecommunication
equipment to government facilities.
That was his job.
And the guy,
the Polish guy,
one of his last jobs with the Intel
service was,
uh,
communications.
So I guess what I'm saying is none of
this shit happens in a bubble and it's
all,
it's all very well mapped out.
The Chinese have a very long view on
things and they are very good at
developing operations like this and so
they've been very successful.
Um,
so we'll,
we'll,
we'll see.
But it's,
it's,
I'm glad that the current administration
at least is calling them out.
I don't believe it's necessarily going
to change their behavior,
you know,
and we'll,
we'll probably get some sort of deal
where they'll claim to look just a
couple of years ago,
they agree with President Obama to stop
their cyber shenanigans and they didn't,
so they just changed the way that they
did it.
You know,
that's,
that's the world we live in.
But I think it is important to make a
stand.
Right?
Yeah.
There's some of that the tech people are
saying that they think it's
preposterous.
When they were talking about the ban on
android phones,
some of the tech people say that doesn't
make any sense,
but what you're saying is it goes far
beyond the actual phones itself.
And it's really the,
the mission of the actual company
itself.
Yeah.
I'm saying that,
that there is no way that Huawei and,
and other important
Chinese companies are solely privately
owned and,
or have the ability to tell the Chinese
authorities that they will not spy on
their behalf.
It just not happen.
It's just not happening.
You have to,
you have to go a long ways,
uh,
to come up with that sort of naive
viewpoint that says that a Chinese
company is going to put its foot down
until present g absolutely not.
We will not do anything to harm another
nation's country or a company horse.
Shit they've spent,
they've spent generations now decades,
uh,
jumpstarting their industry and moving
up the food chain on the global economy
by hoovering up everything possible out
there.
So if someone like a
tech wizard got ahold of one of their
routers,
can have they been able to detect
something in there that doesn't belong
or some sort of a back door or some sort
of a way that they could tap in.
It's like if you were,
you know,
you were apple and you were sending data
to Raytheon or whatever and you're going
back and forth,
they could tap in through that as it had
been proven that there's a device like
that.
Yeah.
A former NSA director Mcconnell back in,
uh,
2015,
I think early 2015 came out and NSA came
out with an official statement and it
said every major US corporation of any
consequence has been,
um,
uh,
attacked and exploited by Chinese.
And we have never,
ever not found Chinese malware within
their systems.
Wow.
That was ever four years
malware being software.
Right,
right,
right.
Is there anything in the hardware
itself?
Uh,
yes.
In,
in,
in a sense that,
um,
yes,
in,
in a sense of like,
I'm trying to remember the name of it,
but not doing very good job.
Um,
if you have,
uh,
access to or understanding of physical
hardware,
then you can,
uh,
affect easier,
you can affect a physical control of
systems.
Right.
So,
uh,
stuxnet,
remember,
I don't know if you remember,
stuxnet was exactly,
it was an attack on Iran.
Um,
the shut down their nuclear program,
right,
exactly.
To,
uh,
essentially what it did was it took over
control of some centrifuges over spawn.
Them they heated about broke and it was
a virus.
And it was,
it was an piece of software that was
able to impact the,
the,
you know,
physical equipment.
Uh,
it took control of those systems,
um,
because in part,
uh,
whoever perpetrated it had much better
understanding of that gear.
Right.
Or had access to that gear.
And that's a,
that's an important part of,
of this.
And it's happened several times since
then.
And I'm,
you know,
I'm not disclosing anything because it's
all it's been written about.
I'm sure it'll be a movie at some point,
but,
um,
that is,
uh,
that's a concern.
I'm far more worried about a company
like Huawei with,
it's a integration into,
uh,
allied,
um,
our allies,
uh,
telecommunications systems than I am
about sort of the individual sale of
phones.
And you know what that means,
that look,
you know,
Amazon and all the others are gathering
more data on the average American then,
you know,
uh,
US government or anybody else's
government is doing it at this point.
Let me ask you this,
cause this is something that just came
up and we were trying to figure out with
nonsense or not.
My friend Adam was here the other day
and we're talking about Toyota trucks
and he didn't Google Toyota trucks just
discussing it.
And he said since then his mentions had
been filled with these little
advertisements for Toyota trucks.
How's that work?
Um,
you know how you talk to Siri?
Yes.
Yeah.
Um,
it,
it's,
it's simple voice rec recognition.
It,
it's,
it's a carry over from the old days of
you know,
optical readers and how,
we all thought it was incredible that
you could take a piece of paper,
put into a system and it would like take
that information that was on that piece
of paper and now it was on a database
that you could access and manipulate.
And so,
you know,
voice recognition is no different in the
sense that,
so if,
if,
if for example,
if I had this switched on and it happens
to people on the,
I'm sure all the time walking around
their house,
they'll say something and all of a
sudden Alexa will come on and go,
oh,
I couldn't find a result for that.
But do you want to listen to Ella
Fitzgerald or whatever?
It's always on.
It's always listening,
right?
And you can do that with anything like
this TV right here if you want it to.
A few,
if I knew that TV was going to go into
the office of the deputy foreign
minister of a country hostile to our
interests,
I could turn that thing into a receiver,
obviously.
Right.
And if I could get my hands on that
before delivery,
that's a wonderful thing.
Now I've got this in there and it's like
the old days when you would have to go
in on a,
an entry operation and you know,
you silent drills and put a,
uh,
you know,
a device in the wall.
Now,
you know,
we've delivered a TV now I get,
I get it,
you know,
video too.
Hey,
good for me.
So that Shit's always on,
you know,
in a sense.
And um,
so a regular phone that you get if you
just buy an iphone and you have Siri
turned on so we could say,
Hey Siri,
and it turns on that phone is always
listening to you.
Well,
uh,
then now we're getting in over my head,
but it could be,
I mean,
it is,
is it possible?
Is it,
is it capable of doing that?
Yes.
Could you do that?
Um,
uh,
as an intentional operation?
Sure.
Um,
is it happening because apple wants to
do it and they want to get better
understanding of consumer preferences
and things?
I have no idea that that's above my pay
grade.
But I will say from an operational
perspective,
sure.
Yeah.
You from an operational perspective,
right.
But like it would kind of be scandalous
if we found out that apple is listen to
everything that you say and then they're
sending them information to these
companies and then they're trying to
sell you whatever you were bringing it
up.
But it's one,
it's really,
if you think about it,
it's only one step above what they do
anyway,
which is,
I mean,
if I go in here and I searched Toyota,
right?
You know,
I'm an,
I'm in the same situation.
I'm fucking inundated with Toyota
mentions right after.
So,
you know,
it's,
it's like the next iteration of that.
And I suspect that people would,
you know,
that some folks would be outraged,
but I'll bet people would just live with
it.
Right.
We seem to be willing to give up a lot
of shit,
you know,
as long as we don't think that
governments doing it right.
If it's,
if it's google,
if it's Google in somebody,
we seem to be fine with it.
But if it's like,
fuck it,
if it's at NSA,
then now our best,
but that's not who's fucking making jack
off of these things.
Right?
Right.
So it's Amazon,
Google and all these companies that are
using it to sell your data to make a lot
of money.
Anyway.
What do you got Jamie?
Centers call for investigation of
T-mobile,
sprint,
verizon and att and t for selling
location data.
Phone companies know where you are.
Lawmakers want them to stop selling that
information until they could figure out
how to tax it.
That seems,
what do they sell in that location?
Data for?
They want to know how many people are in
certain areas.
Is that the idea?
Is that the APP is telling you where
anyone could,
you can buy that information and find
anybody's a location.
But look,
they do these things now where there's a
billboard,
they'll put a billboard up in a,
in a,
in a square,
right?
Um,
and you'll walk by and the billboard has
the ability to see where the eyeballs
are,
right?
So you'll look and they'll say,
oh yeah,
it's looking at me that bill boys
looking at me.
So that's a success,
right?
I've scored a hit or a view and that was
the old days.
It was like,
you know how you know,
how many clicks or how many fields where
it's got a camera.
There's a,
there's a ability for that billboard to
sense.
And again,
this,
I go overboard if I start talking
technical and someone will call me out
and say,
well,
that's not exactly how it works.
But uh,
in simplistic terms,
yeah,
it's a,
it's an ability to monitor,
um,
pedestrian traffic to understand,
you know,
uh,
people's interests and to further refine
so that they can sell a shit better.
Mac,
your outdoor advertising interactive,
this is putting your phone directly up
to it.
This,
this is like you committing that Ooh,
there,
but there is also what he's talking
about to this,
what he started with.
This guy's talking about,
what's his name again?
Who Was it?
So this you walk up to a phone that's in
the photo,
you hold your phone up to it,
it sends a signal to your phone.
It seems like it's always Samsung knows
it.
Only Samsung phones.
Maybe just a galaxy.
Add this advertisement.
I have a song for you.
These are galaxy ads,
but if you can do a one way transaction,
that transaction can be two away easily,
obviously.
Right.
And it has to be to some degree because
there has to be an exchange of,
of,
you know,
sort of a handshake.
So I didn't know that billboards are
staring at you though.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's a new,
pretty crazy shit.
Look,
I mean,
this you can tracking now understanding
where people are,
right?
As an example,
uh,
you know,
it used to be putting a beacon,
right?
Investigations,
you know,
you put a beacon on a car,
right?
And you'd,
and it was a little clumsy,
but it got better and better as you go
along.
You know,
now it's now it's,
it's,
uh,
it's pretty remarkable,
but you can also think about the
electronics that exist in a,
in a current vehicle and a new vehicle.
Um,
you can,
every one of those has a unique
signature.
So whether it's the tire pressure,
uh,
indicators,
you know,
how you get in your car and it says your
left front tire is low.
Right?
Well,
that's a particular signal.
If I know that signal for that car,
I'll bet I can find that car.
Right.
And it's like,
it's the same with all the other
electronics that exist within a vehicle.
Um,
or just in the shit that we carry
around.
They've all got some kind of signature.
So I,
but again,
I think most people are willing to give
up a surprising amount of privacy for
whatever reason.
Maybe because they're getting accustomed
to it and they're not shocked by
shooting.
Jamie,
what were you saying today that somebody
made a slip up about phone calls?
That the thing you were saying about
the,
um,
the different data that they've
collected.
You were just telling me before the show
about the what?
The some investigation.
That was it that the thing that I was
just talking about.
We find anybody's phone.
No,
you were saying that through the emails
and phone up phone calls and the guide
fucked up by saying phone calls.
I'm having a brain a he just told me
before the show.
But then thinking about a lot of stuff,
smoking a lot of stuff.
I got a lot of shit on my mind right to
brain with that.
Now I'm still thinking about that
hallway thing we were talking about
right before.
If you remember it.
No big deal.
I think it had something to do with the
Mueller investigation.
Yeah.
What do you think wins that can end fuck
that guy.
It's just that means he would scare the
shit out of me if he was looking at my
life.
Cause it seems like that guy takes his
time,
but about two years of worth of time.
One thing I've got,
I remember it was the national security
adviser on CNN last night.
He was talking about Bill Barr is,
um,
the access to information he would
already have and,
and it'll also be gaining,
I guess by becoming the Attorney
General.
They were discussing whether he will,
um,
uh,
to share all the information coming out.
They wanted them to commit to doing
that.
And it was just sort of saying,
I can't commit because I don't know
what's in there yet.
And they were just sort of like giving
their both their sides.
I'm like,
well,
he could know what he would know,
what he will know.
That's all I was sort of saying.
And he sorta cut himself off of sharing
about how much information this guy
might have access to.
It sort of,
it seemed like it.
And he was,
the former national security advisor,
I believe was all that was.
So one of the things that everybody was
scared of was that the NSA was building
some gigantic place somewhere outside of
Salt Lake where they would store every
single phone call that you ever made,
every single email.
Yeah.
Uh,
it,
that's,
that there was that whole stink at one
point about,
uh,
what they were actually holding on to,
right.
The collection of information and there
was some misreporting about how they've
actually got your phone calls,
what would,
they've got us,
they've got number and duration of call.
Right?
I mean that's,
that's the key pieces of information
that they've got.
Um,
could they at some point,
you know,
suddenly decide you're a target of
interest and so we won't,
we will start collecting on your calls.
Yeah.
But was the NSA gathering everybody's
phone conversations now,
but it used to be a thing that you would
have to wire tap somebody.
Like if you're going after the mob,
they had a dad install a bug,
but they don't have to do that anymore.
No.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I mean tech technology now it's,
I mean,
I remember the old days of,
of,
uh,
operations,
right?
I mean,
if we wanted to do a,
we're overseas,
it's compounded incredibly,
it's May really difficult to do
observation posts and listening posts
and everything overseas,
right.
Cause it's not your turf.
And so you've got to come up with a,
I'm an air tight plan,
but it was the same way.
You still had to get physical access,
right to phone lines.
He had that yet the clip off and you had
to,
you know,
then you have to figure out where am I
putting the,
the gear,
where am I going to put the batteries?
How am I going to store this shit?
And then you got listened to it,
right?
And you've got to,
you start,
what happens is it starts collecting
like this.
You start getting mountains,
so tapes,
right?
And you're not getting it real time,
which is a problem.
But nowadays,
no,
it's entirely different.
Um,
but I think,
you know,
if,
if we,
if we look at today's concerns,
right?
If we look at what are people worried
about,
what should they be worried about?
Um,
I know that privacy always comes up.
People always talk about it.
And I guess I keep going back to my same
point,
which was I,
I don't see people with pitchforks and
the torches going down a complainant,
Jeff Bezos that,
you know,
Amazon's collecting massive amounts of
data or you know,
t mobile and sprint and all of these are
our mapping our locations as we move
around.
I just don't see it.
I mean,
that probably raised nobody's interest
for the most part.
You know,
that article that you just pulled up.
Um,
and I,
you know,
I guess in part it's because we become
kind of used to it become accustomed to
it,
so,
so fine.
But,
you know,
what should we be worried about?
Well,
I'll tell you what we should boy up
mostly is a state sponsored activity by
countries whose interests almost never
aligned with ours now would include,
China certainly includes Russia,
was Iran.
The,
the shit that they're doing.
China has a policy,
um,
information domination,
right?
Which means they've determined that the
next war,
the next modern large scale war is going
to be one by whoever has control over
information.
So where are they putting all their
resources?
China knows that they're not going to
build a military that's going to be able
to reach around the globe for the most
part.
Although they're,
you know,
they're beefing up their resources.
What are they doing?
It's cyber and it's space,
right?
So I know a lot of people were,
were kicking the president in the ass
and laughing about space for us because
it is funny,
right?
But the uniforms would be amazing.
But they,
they talk about this,
but China honestly believes and it's
putting their resources into cyber and
to space.
And what does that mean,
wolf?
They're anti satellite technology that
they've been developing and working on
and continue to work on.
The whole point of that is to take
control of communications and
surveillance abilities,
whether it's ours or allies in the event
of something major that happens.
So they would have the ability to shut
off our silence.
No,
and if you do that,
then what does that mean?
Well,
it means you're blind,
right?
And will suddenly walking around with
compasses and maps,
you know,
trying to shoot an asthma,
then figuring out where the hell,
you know,
the target is.
So China is currently developing that or
they have developed something that
they're working on it now.
Yeah.
They're working on now developed.
They developed some of it.
They're,
they're working to get the next
generation.
It's like every nation that has the
resources and ability understands that
and is doing the same.
It's not like we're not,
what is their excuse was they should,
but they don't have an excuse.
They just,
they understand they have the right to
do it.
I mean,
it's not like they,
they,
you know,
right.
As long as it don't use it right.
And in an illegal way,
they have the right to develop the tech.
It's like there's no treaty that says
you can't develop anti satellite
technology.
Right.
There's,
there's,
there's the start treaties.
There's the nuclear,
you know,
conventions that we have with Russia,
which isn't a whole nother interesting
topic because we're now arguing with the
Russians over over,
uh,
the,
the latest nuke agreement that took
place some time ago.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
coming up for renewal sometime soon,
your a year or two years from now.
And the Russians had been cheating on a
previous agreement.
And so we're know now they tried to say
we're cheating on the new one.
And so that's an interesting thing to be
watching.
But the point being is that there's
conventions that try to control the,
the numbers for warheads or for delivery
mechanisms,
missiles or,
or,
uh,
submarines,
whatever bombers,
but not for this new world.
Cyberspace.
The Pentagon's still trying to figure
out what,
uh,
you know,
a war,
uh,
means in cyberspace,
right.
You know,
how do you respond?
What do you know,
what,
what's the threshold,
you know,
and then what's an appropriate response?
Um,
and so,
well,
maybe we'll get there.
Maybe we'll start having these
discussions and create treaties that
will allow that.
But right now,
from China's perspective,
again,
not to beat on China,
but I'm much more concerned about China
for our national security.
There are a much bigger concern than
Russia is.
Russia is punching above its weight and
potent,
you know,
Putin's a Dick,
no doubt about it.
Right?
And they've doing what they always do,
which is metal and democracy.
That's been their methodology for ever
since they've been around.
But you know that that's small potatoes.
They got the GDP of a small European
country,
you know,
and when the oil prices,
are in the toilet,
they really are sucking wind.
So yeah,
we gotta be concerned with Russia and
understand that their interests were
never aligned with ours.
You know,
for the most part may be,
we tried to imagine they were with Syria
and isis and everything,
but Russia is only interested there was
maintaining their leverage and
increasing it and not,
not losing their military foothold
there.
That was their primary interest.
We mirror our values and we mirror our
interest on other countries.
And so we imagined that somehow we're
all in this fight against Isis together.
Oh Shit.
You know,
so,
so yeah,
China's a much bigger issue and we,
and we should be focused on that and to
some degree this administration is,
so that's where I say,
look,
you can't just keep complaining and
bitching and moaning because you don't
like president trump.
There are certain things that are going
on that you should be willing to say
that.
Okay,
that makes sense.
Maybe I don't like the messenger,
but that part of it makes sense.
Is it his personal life?
I mean it was it because of his dealings
with China from the business world that
he understands it better,
that he's more concerned with the,
the imbalance of the,
the trade.
I think what happened was what do,
I know this is speculation,
so hey,
but I suspect that what happened was he
came into it,
um,
focused on the trade imbalance.
Right.
And as he was sitting there and talking
about the trade balance,
more of the conversation from the
National Security Council and from the
agency and others in terms of saying,
well,
yeah,
this is part of the reason why and this
is the long longterm effects of,
of their theft of intellectual property.
This is why in part they've been
successful in these areas.
So I think there was probably more and
more discussion talking about,
uh,
their,
economic espionage and theft of Ip and
that became then an issue for him.
Um,
but I think initially,
and still to this day,
I think the big issue is just he wants
to try to create a win in terms of the
trade imbalance.
Russia seems to us here domestically
leaks,
speaking from,
for myself,
when,
when I think about it,
and I think about the,
the narrative that's been sort of
delivered to us said,
Russia is this military danger.
We're worried about Putin taking over
other countries.
We're worried about Putin's power,
the way he kills dissidence,
the way he kills political opponents and
journalists,
we think about China.
And even with the walway arrests were
like,
Eh,
no one seems to be concerned.
It doesn't seem to light any bulbs over
here.
Now you're right.
I don't know why that is,
except,
you know,
Putin is more like a thug and he's a
visual.
Right,
right.
And also,
I mean,
look,
I,
you know,
he's,
he's been very clear about wanting to
try to rebuild the Soviet Union.
So whether it's Crimea and the
annexation of that,
or where they're taking over eastern
Ukraine,
um,
you know,
or,
or maintaining a position at Georgia,
whatever it is.
Uh,
you know,
certainly,
uh,
you know,
his attacks or the FSB is attacks
overseas against,
you know,
dissidents and others.
Um,
yeah,
he's just more in your face.
He's like Tony Soprano.
Right,
right.
So you can look at that.
China's always been,
you know,
sort of this thing,
right.
And she look,
China's fantastic.
The history is amazing.
You know,
the places are incredible.
I think it's,
you know,
we should be trading with China.
We should be doing a huge amount of
business with China.
We should clear the decks and try to
agree.
We can level the playing field,
but we should also be pragmatic and
realize what they do in terms of their
theft of Ip.
And so,
you know,
because that again,
that probably won't change,
but yeah,
we absolutely should be dealing with
China all the time.
But I think that they've always kind of
been viewed more in more of a
sophisticated fashion,
maybe because Putin has just sort of in
your face.
Um,
and he's,
you know,
he's good at it.
He's very successful.
He says he's a smart son of a bitch,
but he's,
I think he's pretty easy to read,
right?
He's,
he's thuggish and,
um,
he,
you know,
he longs for those days of the Soviet
Union.
So we should understand that everything
he does is because of that is because
he's,
he,
he would love to rebuild the Soviet
Union.
And so we shouldn't be surprised by any
sort of aggressive move that he makes
against his,
his neighbors.
And we should always push back.
Um,
and to be fair,
this administration,
not to beat their drum,
but the actions they've taken against
Russia,
despite the fact that you've got people
calling him a puppet of Putin,
how are more significant than the
previous administration took?
Like,
what has he done the sanctions against,
uh,
you know,
key individuals and companies within
Russia as an example.
Those are the toughest sanctions have
been placed on Russia ever.
Um,
the provision of weapons and a,
and assistance to the Ukrainians,
right?
That was something the previous
administration said,
no,
not going to do that.
You know,
cause we don't,
we don't want any blow back.
Um,
that's,
that's a good thing,
right?
That should be done.
Um,
pushing back against them on the,
on the 2011 nuke a deal.
Right.
And,
or sorry,
on the,
on the previous,
on the start deal prior to the 2011 deal
and calling them out and saying,
look,
you're cheating on this and you,
you know,
you gotta be held accountable.
I mean,
there's certain things there that,
that makes sense then that don't add up
if you talk to somebody who says,
well,
he's an absolute puppet,
and you say,
well,
okay,
he's a puppet,
so why is he doing certain that seem
counter to Russian interests?
And they'll say,
well,
because he's smart and he's like,
he doesn't want to get caught out.
I ain't see it's,
he's playing,
he's playing long game here,
you know,
and he's,
and,
and I'm thinking,
okay,
I,
you know,
maybe,
who knows?
But,
uh,
I haven't,
I haven't strapped on my tin foil hat
yet to get to that point.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
Yeah,
that seems like a complicated one.
If they have some compromising
information about them,
that was always the fear,
right?
Is that they knew something or maybe it
was business dealings.
Maybe it was people peeing on him or,
yeah.
So I'll get that if they had,
if they did not.
And again,
anything I can help in today's world,
anything's possible.
Right.
And I wish we had somebody else in there
who was more elegant and eloquent and
sophisticated and anybody stand out?
Uh,
not right now.
No,
I don't think anybody's going to
challenge it from the Republican side.
And on the democratic side,
I think they're going to get 18 to 20
you know,
potential candidates and there and beat
in their own.
Right.
So it could be a,
it could be a real,
you know,
a slug fest and as they're trying to
establish someone who's a viable
candidate,
kind of like what the Republicans did.
Right.
And we ended up with,
you know,
we ended up with president trump.
And you know how the Democrats,
if they're not careful,
you can end up with the same thing.
Look,
they're talking about Joe Biden.
I,
Joe Biden's an excellent cat.
Right?
So 150 years old,
it's 150 years old and he lost twice
before.
But everybody loves the person that's on
the bench,
right,
right.
Until they get in the game.
And so,
you know,
who knows where they're going to go with
that.
But um,
you know,
could they had this idea that they've
got compromising information on them?
Um,
here's,
uh,
here's what I think is that if Mueller
has figured this out right,
and he's been quiet about it,
and then the most remarkable thing about
this investigation will be that nobody
leaked.
Right?
Because you can't keep a secret in
Washington.
And so the fact that for two years now,
we don't have like that,
that,
that bullet,
you know,
that they think they are going to come
up with some point.
My inclination is to think that,
you know,
Molly's gonna Finish this investigation
issue some findings and nobody's going
to be happy,
right?
Cause there won't be a bullet.
And so the left won't be happy.
The right won't be happy because he'll
still be pointing out the fact that
there was,
you know,
a lot of,
stupid moves on the campaigns part and
that there was,
uh,
inappropriate activity by,
you know,
people like manafort and others.
Uh,
but,
uh,
do I think there's gonna be some smoking
gun?
I don't,
I don't think so because,
and my reason for saying that is because
I've never known Washington not be able
to keep or to,
to be able to keep a secret.
This is the one,
like,
Mueller ever done one of these things
before though.
He seems uniquely calculated.
Yeah.
He's,
he's done this before and um,
and he has,
he's like,
look,
he's a very smart guy and a very
seasoned,
a operator investigator.
Uh,
and he's got good people working for him
and it's absolutely correct to let them
go with this and just let him finish it
up.
Right.
But when is that going to be?
Who knows?
Right,
right.
Nobody had,
they've been talking about,
oh,
he's going to wrap it up next week,
or it's going to wrap it up this week.
He's going to know.
He's not,
you know,
he'll,
he's thinking he's going to wrap it up.
Who knows?
This literally could go onto in the eye,
it's going to have to end before
probably end of this year.
I don't think even he's gonna want to
for political calculations,
let it go into,
to close to 20,
20 in the election.
Right.
So regardless,
even though I don't think he's a
particularly political individual,
I think he's going to see the wisdom of
wrapping it up before then.
Um,
and then letting the chips fall wherever
they do.
What's astonishing to me is how anytime
something does come out on trump,
it just seems to slide right off.
Yeah.
All that is true.
That is true.
Because I think what's happening is
they're just throwing everything out
there every day.
Right.
And it much like,
you know,
our willingness to give up privacy
because we keep hearing about another
hack or another lake or we know that
Amazon's doing this or that.
I think w,
you know,
it's that constant drum beat and that
mudslinging and I think the dems haven't
done themselves any favors.
So the resistance movement of what do we
want to call it?
Um,
because I think people are just immune
to it and it's hardened the trump's base
to think,
you know,
he's under attack every minute,
right.
So I gotta support them harder.
Um,
yeah.
But uh,
you know,
who do you think's going to end up in,
in the race?
I mean,
who's got the best chance?
It's a good question.
I mean,
on the left hand side,
the,
my real fear is that Hillary is going to
run again.
Sorry,
I almost did one of those TV spit takes.
It's possible.
Well,
that lady is crazy.
You know,
one of the things that she said in one
of the more recent interviews,
she said,
I'd like to be president.
Just what do you want to put it on your
resume?
What the fuck does that mean?
I think I could do a great job and
turning this country around.
I have the leadership ability to really
affect a change.
No,
no,
no.
I'd like to be president,
Eh,
I got some time I could do that.
I'm scared of them.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
and you're right.
She May,
but I,
I do think there's going to be so much
pressure on her from the party to just
say,
no,
you can't.
I think she's going to look at that and
go,
I,
there's no chance I can rally the
apparatus around me like I did the last
time.
And because of that,
um,
because even she can't run without the
machine.
Right.
I mean,
that's it.
They've got to figure that out.
So
I just wonder if she has so many people
that owe her favors and she's so deeply
entrenched in the world that she could
somehow,
or another muster up enough support to
give it one more shot.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's,
it's
possible.
I mean,
yeah,
but then you're talking about hurry it
all the way to two.
What to to,
uh,
Kamala Harris,
cory booker,
Tulsi Gabbert Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi.
Gabbard Castro is a veteran.
Young makes a lot of sense.
Very smart,
articulate.
I think she has a real legitimate chance
of getting people excited about a real
future.
Yeah.
I would not,
uh,
you know,
I think it's,
it's time we're close.
We're getting to that point where we'll,
uh,
you know,
we end up with a female president and
hey,
good for us.
Right?
I got no problems.
You know,
there's,
I think it would actually,
you know,
I think it would turn the ship in a nice
direction,
right.
As long as the policies are good,
I don't care who it is,
as long as we're not,
you know,
veering off into,
uh,
you know,
sort of socialist policy,
land and thinking somehow we're going to
all going to end up with a universal
basic income.
You know,
I got a guy coming on and talking about
that.
Andrew Yang.
It
describe universal basic income and what
the benefits would be.
The reason being that they're worried
that automation is going to kill a
gigantic percent is of jobs in
manufacturing,
fast food,
um,
medical field trucks,
all these different things that
universal basic income might actually be
something that we need it certain point
in time because so many jobs will go
away and go away so rapidly.
Do you think that uh,
kills motivation?
That's a good question.
What I thought was maybe,
but maybe if the motivation is not just
to survive,
but the motivation to succeed and do
well,
it would get people to do what they
actually want to do for a living or
chase down what they actually want to do
and get them motivated to,
to have a better life,
not just motivated to live,
follow their passion.
Yes.
It's,
it's hard because when you give people
things for nothing,
right?
You generally do kill their motivation.
I mean,
you look neat.
Look no further than trust fund kids.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I guess I,
that's,
that's a great example.
Most people would go towards,
you know,
welfare,
but I think you're right on the other
end of the spectrum.
To me,
trust fund kids.
I've seen this list lists way they
approach life,
you know,
they just laissez faire just,
I just think that it's really hard for
people to want something better when
they have enough.
They're good.
Yeah.
Everything's good.
They don't have to do anything.
And you don't have to motivate yourself
to do anything to get that money.
Mani.
Yeah.
I don't understand the,
the,
the logistics behind it,
you know,
in terms of how it gets paid,
the actual numbers.
But the,
the part that I,
that worries me is this issue of,
of motivation and ensuring that then,
you know,
everybody's willing to unmask the sofa
and,
and do something productive.
Right.
And it's not just,
we can't be like a,
a nation of people following their
passion because their passion is,
is completely unpredicted or may make
making dream catchers,
pottery loved pottery month.
Dream catchers too.
I got one in my truck.
Um,
and really
what are you doing?
I got a hula girl on the dashboard of my
truck,
which is getting a new engine,
by the way.
Even as we speak,
I had to turn off the wagon here.
It's a grand wagon here.
The old wood paneled Greg Wagon here.
Yeah.
The year that they made at
91 and still drive one of those things.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's a great car and uh,
and but I have to,
I had to rebuild the engine some that
works good.
Like a new one
because this thing is great.
Look that the kids can climb all around
it.
I can drive to the drive in theater and
they can,
they put a back
the hatchback and they'd just sit there
and I do live in the 50s actually.
Yeah.
That with the little clip on speaker
that can bend.
It is fantastic.
You have not a long time.
Is that what you have?
I got the blue.
It's blue with a sand interior fucking
wizard that decided to go with those
wood panels on the side.
It's fantastic.
And then how did that,
how did everybody wake up and decide
that that sucks?
Yeah.
I have a while.
I tell you something.
It's a great suit,
great vehicle.
And it's also,
nobody gets anywhere near me cause that
fucker is made of of all steel.
Yeah,
they're heavy.
And that son of a bitch will plow
through anything,
but it's just a great car and the dog
loves it.
And I can fit all the gloves and the
fishing.
Yeah,
you put the fishing poles in there.
It's all good.
No,
you're kidding.
I'm lucky if I,
if I have breaks,
but don't you want to call with brakes?
Eh,
it's big enough when you work in
security for too long,
you're like,
there's no security now.
Fuck Outta here.
Just nice seat belt doesn't work.
But I've been meaning to fix it.
You have a seatbelt.
The receiver is broken and we're clicks
in.
Yeah,
exactly.
And I've been meaning to get that fixed
cars and being,
when you don't have your seat belt on
and like good luck.
No,
it doesn't talk to me at all.
And you know what else?
Nobody can track me in that car that,
you know what attracted me and that son
of a bitch.
So you just leave your phone at home and
you're fucking,
you're good.
I'm good man.
I'm all pick red boner.
I met a burner.
Hello phone.
I can fit my boner in there too,
which is Kinda just burner phones come
with boners
Trenton,
a burner phone barter.
You got a boner and then,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a great,
it's a great vehicle.
Like I said,
my kids love it.
Mugsy and scooter and Sluggo juicing
that you got it because you can't track
you with it.
And also they can't.
Let me ask you this.
This is a tough one.
I want to ask you to conspiracy one's,
but this one's a tough one.
Michael Hastings,
you know his case.
Do you know story?
Yeah.
What do you think happened there?
Well,
let's,
let's explain what happened.
What,
who he was,
he was a journalist.
He was embedded in,
was it in Iraq during the,
during the war.
He was writing a story for the role for
rolling stone.
And he was writing about which general
was it?
Crystal.
Crystal,
crystal and stay on the crystal.
Yeah.
So he wrote this story and apparently
while this happened,
the Iceland volcano went off.
So they,
they suspended air travel.
So he was stuck there far longer than he
was supposed to be and people got
comfortable with this guy being around.
Right.
And so they behave the way they behave.
They made some jokes about things.
He apparently made some jokes about
Obama.
This guy put this,
Michael Hastings put all this stuff and
rolling stone.
Um,
it wound up being a huge scandal.
Mcchrystal had to step down and there
was a lot of people that hated that guy
and a lot of people loved mcchrystal and
he was a highly respected general.
Yeah,
absolutely.
He had a step down from his position and
next thing you know,
x amount of time later,
this guy drives his car 150 miles an
hour into a tree.
It blows up.
The engine goes flying the whole deal.
Uh,
the conspiracy theory was that there was
a way,
cause he had a brand new Mercedes,
there was a way that they could take
over the controls of your vehicle,
the acceleration,
the braking steering,
and they could do all this remotely.
If they put something in your car,
like we were talking about,
if you could get ahold of this
television,
you could turn that television to a
receiver.
Right.
Do you think that is possible that
someone could have gotten a hold of his
car and made him suicide himself?
Uh,
two parts to it.
one is,
is it possible that you can take control
of a vehicle,
a modern vehicle?
Yes.
Not,
not that,
not the woody,
not the woody.
Yes,
we call it.
Um,
but,
uh,
so yes,
it's absolutely possible that you can
take those is no two ways about
acceleration,
steering everything.
Yeah.
If you've got,
and,
um,
and I mean,
think about people should think about
it.
They think about the,
the Onstar or think about the ability
for your car to send data,
uh,
to the,
to the vehicle manufacturer.
Right?
Right.
To tell them,
you know,
what's going on with your vehicle.
Um,
that's a,
that's a handshake operation,
right?
Once you do that,
that that means there's an exchange of
information.
What does that mean?
Well,
that means you can access,
can you access that information?
Sure,
of course you can.
Does that mean you can then take
physical controls short?
That's it's,
it's an,
it's just another iteration of the
exchange of information,
right?
Software can take control of physical
systems so that,
yeah.
So the first part is yes.
Is it possible that that car could have
been taken over shore?
Uh,
do I think that's what happened?
I have no idea.
I really don't.
But,
um,
it's,
it's certainly a possibility.
I mean,
when I hear people talk about,
you know,
certain conspiracy theories,
I looked at it and go,
there's just no fucking way that can
happen.
Like what one,
one d say no fucking one.
Uh,
actually I have a hard
time thinking of one.
Um,
uh,
I liked it,
the theory that with every burner phone
you get a boner.
That's,
I just,
I can't imagine that could happen.
But it sounds good.
I think I'm good.
Misunderstood.
What I'm saying is you get the burner
phone because you have a boner already
trying to get rid of it.
Oh,
I didn't see the owner.
Yeah,
I got the priorities.
So until you secretary to get a burner
phone to meet her at the old
hotel,
how the,
Oh man.
Just like Jeff Bezos and he's $70
billion down the down the toilet.
Oh yeah.
That's,
how did they get his text messages?
That's a good fucking cybersecurity.
Yeah.
They got his text messages to his
mistress.
Yeah.
Who knows how that happened.
So it,
unless maybe she maybe meaning Mrs
Bayzos,
maybe she hired a,
uh,
you know,
some dodgy investigator to come up with
that.
Well,
I noticed that it was an iphone.
No visit an iphone.
And he had an I pad and she had the
password to the IPAD.
She could get all those messages.
Yeah.
But it's a,
that,
what do they live?
They live in Washington,
right?
State of Washington.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So I guess that's communal,
I think.
Yeah.
She,
well,
they started the company together.
She helped him.
Yeah.
So that's a wrap.
But you know,
whatever,
70 billion.
Yeah.
It's rough to give away 70 billion.
But let's be completely honest.
If you're,
if you have $70 billion and you notice
whether you have 70 or a hundred.
Yeah,
yeah.
All kind of,
you might be an asshole.
You know the difference?
Yeah.
How the fuck do you even feel it?
If she takes 70 billion?
This is lifestyle change cause you have
to get rid of one of his jets.
Like what happened?
He's got to give up cable.
Does he have a bionic smaller ring for
his mistress?
But she's not even a is apparently they
were separated.
We're not going to get his girlfriend.
Oh Geez.
Really?
Yeah.
Okay.
So they're saying he was cheating on his
wife,
but he wasn't really because they were
separated.
Yeah.
You would think that that's fair game,
but I'm sure that it's anyway,
it's going to be costly.
She's so hot.
Oh,
she's so cool.
Mrs Bayzos or one?
The new one.
Oh.
Oh,
I think they're friends.
I think she and Mrs Bayzos.
We're friends.
They're friends.
Yeah.
It's all going to be very amicable.
They fucking circle.
They know what they're doing.
Coyotes,
man doing,
they just take their time,
their patient wolves.
I think he's,
I think it's,
it's interesting because I think he,
um,
he's changed if you look at Bayzos over
the years,
right?
Yeah.
And you look at the way he is now just
as physical appearance.
You can just,
you can just tell that that money,
yeah.
Money probably hired a personal trainer
too,
but he's got the money,
but he's gonna probably have to let them
go now.
Can't afford that shit anymore.
I lost 70 billion.
Well,
the smart thing would honestly be to,
for him to give away half.
Don't even duke it out with lawyers.
I don't take too long.
But he,
no prenup agreement.
There's no prenuptial Koala.
It's understood that Ms. Sanchez has
sent text messages to a friend showing
off for a new relationship with the
billionaire and the friends sent them to
the inquirer.
Water con you fucking dumb ass.
Oh Damn.
She's hot though.
She looks like that actress.
I can't remember her name.
Yeah,
the one on modern family.
Yes.
Yeah,
I could see what she sees at him.
He's like,
yeah,
he's,
he's uh,
you know,
it's the thin neck in relationship with
the large head chicks.
Love that.
Jeff,
you're still,
he loved that look.
Yes.
Such a man.
And he sent her like naked selfies too.
Ah,
no,
not him too.
I think you did.
What is that?
You don't,
why did dudes think that women want to
look at their junk?
Right?
I mean,
I know.
I just don't,
I don't get that part of it.
I don't get what makes you think unless
you really been drinking that you're
going to go,
you know what?
I'll bet she really wants to see my,
my balls.
Girls do.
Some girls are crazy good ones.
Damn.
She's hot buttons.
Warren Sanchez has been the romantic
relationship with jet blue.
She's hot since April,
2018 or Sunday long.
So it's a long term thing.
June,
July.
That's enough.
He's probably shot so many loads.
Wow.
He's in love now.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Do a Donald Trump had something to say
about it.
What do you say?
So sorry to hear the news about Jeff
Bozos being taken down by a competitor
who's reporting I understand is far more
accurate than the reporting in his
lobbyist newspaper,
the Amazon Washington Post.
Hopefully the paypal soon be placed in a
better,
more responsible hands.
Yeah,
he wants,
he watched it off.
He wants her to get it.
He wants Bayzos to not have the
Washington Post,
which is highly critical.
The president,
while the inquirer has been known to
kill stores,
critical,
the president.
Oh,
so the enquirer got ahold of the story.
I get it,
but you know it was,
I'll bet Jeff Bezos in president's mind.
I'll bet is his opinion went up when he
saw that picture of Sanchez probably.
I'll bet he was like,
but then you probably read the text
messages and like,
ah,
amateur,
come on.
Come on.
What are you telling her that uh,
what,
what are you going to do?
Jump right out of the frying pan.
Get right back into the fire.
How about you go to fucking Ibiza and
dance on the couch with a hundred of
those broads?
Take a little time off is what you're
saying.
Jeff needs a,
it needs a coach.
Isn't that interesting how dude's do I
think by wealthy dude seem to do that
more than others.
They seem to go straight from one
relationship immediately into another
one.
Whereas I think that the average dude I
think is doing what you're thinking,
which is like,
yeah,
I'm gonna take some time down.
Well the average dude also isn't running
a gigantic multinational corporation
like Amazon.
The thing about that is the amount of
time that that guy has to dedicate to
his job,
it's gotta be just unfathomable.
I mean,
I can't imagine what,
what is involved and that guy's day to
day activity and he seems ruthless as
fuck and very hands on.
So how did,
he probably doesn't have time to go to a
visa if the average guy had anywhere
close to a hundred billion dollars
though.
Oh,
they just bail.
Should everyday be strip clubs cash out
to yeah,
no more showing up at the office.
Cash out.
Cash me out and keep going.
Catch me now
I do podcasts.
I keep showing it.
I wouldn't have any ads,
no ads,
and be like,
ah,
I'm good.
That'd be nice.
I'm going to give you guys this shift
for free.
I looked at the overheads expensive.
I need I just fucking building.
And it's an amazing building,
by the way,
Internet.
Thank you.
Have you ever showed it?
I mean,
if you'd like displayed it right at the
gym you've got is fantastic.
Yeah.
I so put some pictures of it up,
but yeah.
You know what,
man?
For me it's important because I'm not
busy like Jeff Bezos,
but I'm fucking busy.
I need to get all my shit done in one
spot,
so on when I can.
I come here early,
banging out a workout in the morning.
I get my fucking sauna in float float in
a sauna here.
I didn't know.
I didn't know the a tank.
Yeah.
I've got a sauna.
It's,
it's for me,
it's nice.
I can get everything done in one spot.
It actually saves me money just because
the amount of time that I have now.
I,
by the way,
uh,
I did not say it at the outset,
but I should say that show you didn't
Boise,
Idaho.
It's a beautiful place.
Uh,
telling me that was fucking brilliant.
Thank you.
That's show was fantastic.
Fun.
People were talking about that for a lot
of long time afterwards.
It was,
and it was a great crowd.
Does a giant ass place.
Yeah,
it was fun.
It was really good time.
I mean,
is it for people listening?
It was a massive,
it's a Taco bell arena,
which is the best venue in,
in,
in the city.
It's a big venue and there was lines
just blocks and blocks and blocks before
they opened the doors and even after
they opened doors because there was so
many people.
Boise is a great town,
man.
I was,
I had heard how good it was.
That was my first time ever go in there
and I was blown away.
The people were super friendly.
It's gorgeous there.
Everything is clean.
I don't want to talk about it.
I don't want anybody to move in.
People are moving in.
I think I we talked about that.
Yeah.
Before the show started,
was it Wall Street Journal wrote an
article saying it's,
it is sometime ago,
a couple of months ago or whenever it's
saying it's fastest growing city in the,
in the country.
Once you go,
there you go.
Okay.
Like if you brought your wife there and
he said,
look,
this is what we're going to move here.
She was like,
we got a lot of people from California
coming up there.
Of course say that much.
Yeah.
And some good friends of mine who is
living down on the beach right now,
uh,
they,
they seriously looking at it.
They've been looking at property and
think you maybe wolves,
uh,
with coyotes and the wolves.
No,
well,
no,
we haven't seen them.
We got them,
but we haven't seen.
But we've got,
we had a coyote in our neighborhood for
quite awhile.
He kind of became famous and they're,
they're good looking coyotes.
You know,
east coast,
they're,
yeah,
they're like skinny and frail.
They looked like Wiley Coyote.
But out here,
out west a up there,
they're well fed.
Well,
you have so much wildlife.
Yeah.
You know,
Idaho has an incredible mule deer
population.
Do you have amazing El Population?
Elk Hunting
is,
yeah.
Oh,
it's beautiful.
Yeah.
Decided to go off the grid.
That's one of my prime spots.
Not telling nobody.
I'll tell you.
Let me know.
I'm going to pave the way,
man.
It's so,
it's,
yeah,
it's a good spot.
Um,
and uh,
and I,
I got to stop talking about it too,
because I get a lot of shit for saying
nice things about it,
but I can't,
I can't help it.
It's a zero sum.
Yeah.
Unheralded spots in this country.
And I think that's most certainly one of
them.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a gang of other ones too though,
you know,
and it's,
it's really the west in the west,
like the,
these areas that just don't have the
gigantic populations but have everything
else.
Gorgeous scenery and the mountain air
and just God damn.
Yeah.
The fishing is,
that's the other thing.
Oh my God.
I'm sure.
Fly Fishing and my oldest boy,
uh,
scooters is a really gotten into fly
fishing and he's got a great mindset for
it.
Right.
You know,
he just,
he's,
he's one of those guys,
he could be out there for a few hours,
not catch anything and still have a
great time.
And really you've got other kids,
like my,
my two younger kids,
you know,
they just,
they want a dynamite fish.
Right.
They just want to get the fucking fish
and get on with it.
And so they don't,
they're not going to fly fish at anytime
soon,
but scooters all about it.
And uh,
yeah,
not to,
uh,
not to bang on about that,
but basically all the wildlife
activities or all the outdoor
activities.
Yeah.
We got more river frontage,
more river mileage than any state except
for Alaska.
Really?
Yeah.
Uh,
we got more and the,
and so the Whitewater is fantastic.
It's great rafting up there.
The climbing's fantastic mountain
biking.
I mean,
we'd jump on our bikes,
we can be up in the foothills in
literally about seven minutes and then
spend the afternoon and not see anybody.
I mean,
it's crazy.
And we live right in the center of town
basically.
And it's,
you know,
so anyway,
yeah.
Talk Dad,
don't tell him about,
oh,
I've got a note from a,
and go from mugsy my,
my youngest boys teacher,
he's like seven years old and he's not
like seven years old.
He has seven years old.
It's like,
Hey,
he's approximately somewhere in the
range.
Yeah,
yeah.
I tried to hide his actual age for
security reasons.
And so anyway,
we got a note from his teacher sang,
happened a little bit of trouble
finishing his assignments on time and he
just kind of wanted to check in with you
to see how to motivate them.
And this was just yesterday and I got
this message as did my absolutely
fantastic wife.
And uh,
so we had a funny conversation about,
well,
how do we respond to that?
I mean like,
he's seven years old,
but all of it working for a living.
How do you motivate them to cut and
paste faster or something?
But,
so I,
you know,
all I could think of was food,
right?
Like my retriever,
he,
you know,
he's food motivated my dog.
And so I'm figuring,
you know,
monk,
he's the same way.
You know,
you give them a cupcake and he'll finish
that assignment.
So I had no idea I was really stymied,
you know,
because I think,
I know we all,
you know,
I mean our kids are,
like everybody else,
you always feel your kids,
hey great kids are smart and everything,
but you know,
and I,
so I give
her,
I give the teacher a lot of credit,
you know,
for being focused like that.
But at the same time I stepped back and
I looked at,
I go and it's okay if he wants to slack
off a little bit,
he's 77 exactly.
How do we have this obsession with
getting kids to the bus?
Or like I was a,
I have a friend who's going to put their
kid in a Waldorf school and we were
talking about that and I guess they
don't even teach him to read until the
third grade.
And my wife was like,
get the fuck Outta here with that
because my youngest daughter's in the
third grade,
she reads great.
I mean we read every night,
she reads perfectly.
And I'm like,
imagine if she hadn't even started
learning how to read yet that,
that,
that and that,
that's what opens up everything else.
You can't,
you can't delay it.
That part of it.
And,
but yeah.
So yeah,
I know we finish every evening with
they,
the kids have to read.
Right.
Get on,
you know,
finished reading too.
That's the other thing.
Like I don't think it's a bad thing to
have kids read,
but what I do,
what does you heard it here?
First verse,
she'll taking a country writer.
She'll stand on reading.
I support it.
What does concern me though is homework,
cause uh,
you know,
my 10 year old,
sometimes she cries,
she's got so much home and she's like,
we're all day to school and no have to
do two hours of women.
There's probably got activities to
sports activities and so that consumes
gymnastics bunch of other shit too.
It's these kids,
they want these kids to grow up to
become hugely successful.
And you know,
they,
they push him so hard and everybody in
the community is this,
is this,
when you're in these wealthy communities
too.
That's the other thing is all these
other people,
they all,
everybody's working so hard.
They want their kids to work so hard to
like Jesus.
I'm not,
I'm,
I'm in this weird spot where I'm an,
I'm an an insider outsider.
It's cause I'm in there and I kind of
work hard.
You work hard shit.
What are you doing?
Kind of work hard.
It's not really work.
None of it's,
I have fucking scam this system.
I got three fake jobs.
UFC fake job,
standup comedy,
fake ass job,
podcasting.
Definitely a fake job.
I got three fake jobs.
They're twins is the toughest.
The toughest is right now.
I don't know what's the toughest,
uh,
probably uh,
stand up.
Stand up is the hardest to pull off.
How long did you,
let me ask you this,
how long did it take for like the set
that you did up in Boise,
which was was fantastic.
How long did that run?
I didn't,
I was laughing my ass off so I didn't,
I don't,
I did an hour and we'd go like an hour
and 15 minutes and that took me,
that was what,
when I went up to boise was a couple
months before a film my special.
So that was the end of my run.
So what I do is I develop an act for
like a year.
I tour with it for a year and then at
the end of that tour I film a special,
okay.
So it takes me two years to put together
where it's I fucking hammer that Samurai
sword down,
Polish it,
and it's live performance,
you know,
it's fucking weird.
Sometimes one night a bit kills the
other bit.
T night it comes out a little clunky.
You never sure how to do it.
It's,
it's a constant thing of an evolving it
and moving it and changing it.
Do you ever just drop something?
Yeah,
I mean that's all the time it's been
working and then you go and you think,
fuck it,
I don't want to do it anymore.
Yeah,
yeah.
You have to be enthusiastic.
Yeah.
Like in the beginning of Standup,
you treat your jokes like their tools.
Like uh oh this is a phillips head.
I need a phillips head screwdriver.
I'll fit that in there.
And then after a while you realize like,
okay,
let me do what I like.
I'm going to talk about shit that I
like.
And then you have,
and then you realize,
well the art form is trying to figure
out how to make ideas funny.
And then then it becomes,
if these ideas are funny to me,
I've got to figure out a way to get them
funded for other people.
But if they're not funny to me,
I'm not interested.
And then so what are you doing here?
You put something together and then you
test it out on the kids are,
and homer,
no,
don't have to tell you.
No,
no.
You take it to like a small place,
right?
I take it to clubs.
I go to the Ice House and the comedy
store and the Improv and I,
I go to these local places in La and I
might do,
like last night I did three shows and
uh,
I'll,
I'll do that all the time.
I'll do that.
I'll do four shows,
I'll do one show at the Improv,
three at the comedy store.
I do that all the time.
How long did the shows h I mean,
each,
each sets our,
okay.
Half hour,
sometimes less.
Sometimes must be exhausting.
I mean,
in a way,
talk about how it's a fake job,
but yeah,
I mean,
you gotta get up in front of people.
You don't know what the reaction's going
to be.
That's the best job that I do,
but also the most work.
But it's the best out of the fake jobs
that I have.
That's the best fake job because it's
the most fun.
Like,
you know,
the Boise thing was like 11,000 people.
If you crush in front of 11,000 people,
that feeling is just,
when you hear the roar,
like you hit a punchline,
you hear the roar of the crowd.
It's like there's nothing like that.
Nothing like that in the world.
That was,
it was,
uh,
again,
anybody get a chance to go see,
go see a show.
Cause this one's just go see my netflix
specials so you can see that thing now
you have to pay more for Netflix now.
Yeah.
What is it like 10 bucks?
Yeah,
17% more.
I think they're going to charge.
Really?
Yeah,
they can.
Yeah.
Good.
I have so much good shit though.
Like if you want to just waste your life
and sit in front of the TV,
it's crazy.
Like when we were kids,
maybe that's your passion.
So you get that universal basic income.
And my following my passion means I got
to sit and watch every episode of uh,
Andy Fart under the sheets.
And there's a lot of people doing that
right now.
I don't know if that's bad is,
I mean,
yes it is,
but then doesn't that open the door for
the,
the people that aren't going to be like
that?
Like look,
less people out there really actually
trying to get ahead.
I think the people that are going to try
to succeed are always going to try to
succeed.
I think that's true and I think so.
I think that's,
maybe that's an argument against it
also,
which is said like,
I don't think it's going to unlock a
whole treasure trove of innovators.
Right?
If suddenly
you give people money and say,
okay,
you don't have to go,
uh,
poor coffee or,
or flip burgers or you know,
uh,
clean up that road or whatever you're
going to do for a living,
you can follow your passion.
I don't think we're going to find some
exponential increase in the number of
people inventing the wheel.
I just think that it's just going to be
a lot more people farden under the
blankets or something.
I don't know.
They might be right,
but the only good that I think could
come out of it as a less people were in
abject poverty and less people were
desperate.
So it might reduce crime.
You might have lazy people,
but you might also have less people that
are inclined to steal things or do
something that's illegal because their
basic needs are taken care of.
That's valid point.
I read something that's,
it stunned me.
It was,
it was on a plane flying to,
uh,
to La.
Um,
and I read an article about this does
strike right.
The teachers here in Los Angeles,
big strike,
Los Angeles unified a school authority
or whatever it's called,
and it was just before they,
they went on strike.
But it talked about the problems at the
school district has,
and I don't know whether this statistic
is right.
I read it numerous times because I was
so surprised by it.
80% of the,
uh,
families that use the Los Angeles public
school system are at the poverty level
or below.
And that means of course,
also that they rely on the free meal
assistance,
right.
That the schools provide,
which is kind of what was the point of
the story was like,
the schools are closed right now.
And so,
you know,
kids aren't getting a chance to eat
because they,
that's their only chance to get to eat.
Right.
But that number was stunning.
That's crazy.
Right?
Uh,
so I don't,
I,
I meant to look into it and do more
research to see whether the article is
actually correct or not,
but hey,
it was in the newspaper,
so it must be true,
right?
I Dunno about that.
Anyway.
Uh,
yeah,
he's a disturbing number.
It's a very disturbing number.
But it also talked about how 12%,
I think 12% of all kids that go to high
school here in Los Angeles then go on to
college,
12%.
And uh,
it was a similar number that never get
out of high school and it's even worse
than a place like New York City public
schools.
So I guess the point being is a public
school system is,
is it's dog shit in the larger urban
centers.
It's got some real problems.
And I think a lot of those people that
are the really sad things,
a lot of those people that are at the
poverty line or below work hard,
it's not a lack of motivation and said,
just don't have opportunities.
They don't know what to do.
That not doing it the right way.
They don't have guidance.
They never learned correctly when they
were young,
single parent.
They've,
what's the two or three jobs?
Um,
and no,
but I love California has got all sorts
of interesting issues.
I mean,
there's,
uh,
you know,
talking to some folks and they said,
uh,
a quarter of the nation's homeless
people live here in California.
25% of the nation's homeless people live
in California and a place to live.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
yeah,
he's raised in the last few days.
Most of the times it's beautiful
weather.
Hey,
can't complain about the weather anyway,
but it is crazy.
And,
and it also talks about how a lot of
those people,
they work,
but they're homeless,
right?
The cost of housing.
And so you've got people that have a job
but they're living in their cars,
right?
Because they can't afford housing,
whether it's in San Francisco or Los
Angeles.
Insanity.
Yeah.
That is,
that place is insanity.
So your point about the basic universal
income,
I take that point.
I see what that,
you know,
if it was possible to pay for it and uh,
and again,
you know,
kind of do this thing where you,
you're monitoring this issue of
motivation so you're not creating
another follow on generation of just
complete slack acids.
Then I think that's it.
That's a really valid point.
I,
my concern would be people that didn't
appreciate it and people that felt
entitled,
like they felt like someone owed them
that money.
You're going to have that.
I mean this is the,
this is the biggest problem that people
have with socialism and socialist
attitudes that some of these kids that
are coming up right now,
they look at what they call income
inequality,
what they don't look at his effort
inequality.
Like some people put in more fucking
work and are smarter.
They've figured their way through the
game better than you have been doing it
for 50 years or whatever they brain.
Right.
I couldn't agree with him more in the
sense that I,
I never begrudged anybody.
I never got pissed off with a rich
person because they were rich.
Right.
I think it,
hey,
that's good.
I'd like to be rich.
Right.
So I might want to talk and find out,
hey,
how'd you do it?
Or how'd you do it?
And yeah,
it's a system sometimes,
you know,
set up so that once you have some money,
you can get more money.
Well,
of course the fuck it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
if I have some money,
I can invest that money and make more
money if I'm smart about it,
if I do it right.
Yeah.
If you do it right.
But I absolutely,
I don't,
and I don't begrudge the idea that's it.
So that's part of it is also fairly
steeped in the idea that,
you know,
we're living in a very,
uh,
unique country.
Right.
And I do worry sometimes that people
don't,
you know,
I,
even family and I've got some friends
and others who were just constantly
pissing and moaning about this place.
And I'm thinking,
I spent almost all my life over and shit
holes around the world and I,
there is no other place I would rather
be as a country.
And I know that's,
you know,
it's jingoistic or whatever.
But uh,
honest to God,
I still believe,
and if you go someplace and you've
talked to somebody in some fifth world,
they will also have,
my experience has been any way,
uh,
maybe you're listening in,
your experience is different,
but that's the way it works is that
they'll think if I go to America,
if I can get to America and I work hard,
I can,
I can be successful.
And that I think is still true.
And that's what I worry about with
entitlements and thinks that that make
kill that belief.
And you're right,
incoming inequality.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
but it's your right,
you work harder now.
It doesn't always happen,
but life's not supposed to be fair.
It's,
well,
it's maybe it's supposed to be fair,
but it's not fair.
So
sorry,
I was just supposed to be life.
It's definitely not fair.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
I,
I completely see your point and I,
and I agree with it.
I think that the real concern is that
people don't appreciate already how
great they have and what incredible
opportunity they have.
And if we increase w w we give them more
benefits with less effort than you're
going to develop more of this attitude
that we find disturbing,
which is people that don't have an
appreciation for literally the greatest
experiment in self government,
the world has ever known.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I,
but I think also that there's,
there's parts of it that need to be
looked at.
Like there's,
it,
there's an interesting study about,
uh,
about college and graduation rates from
college for,
um,
for,
uh,
disadvantaged folks.
You know,
and that was again,
why they made it easier for tuition
assistance.
Right?
So the idea was we want to expand the
college ability for everybody,
which is a great idea.
Right?
But what they found was they expanded
the,
the college opportunity for everybody.
But over the past decade,
decade and a half,
fewer people from the lower income,
uh,
categories have been graduating.
Right?
So you've,
what you've done is you said,
come on in.
It's like,
you know,
it's like a special operators,
right?
If,
if,
if you lower the bar,
right?
Right.
Um,
and this is where I'm going to get in
trouble probably.
I'll talk about the marines and you
know,
allowing women into combat elements.
I know,
oh my God,
well what did they do?
Well,
you lower the bar.
[inaudible] you make it,
you know?
Okay,
well not enough of them could get
through the course.
So I'm going to change the regulations.
And so if you change the regulations,
what they found,
where the college was,
if you,
if you increase that pool of people
going,
it doesn't mean that they're going to be
successful.
Right?
And now what you've done is you've kind
of saddle them with some college debt
and they didn't graduate.
So they're still earning what a high
school graduate earns and the system
doesn't work.
And so I think sometimes just the idea
of throwing money at the problem or,
or,
or it doesn't,
it's not helpful if we don't think it
through and then assess the results.
So,
but yeah,
that,
that whole marine experiment,
I think
they're,
they're catching it laid in the chain
and I think it's good to give people the
opportunity to succeed and to advance
themselves.
But if you really want to address it as
a systemic problem,
you got to get to the root of it,
which is these unbelievably horrible
neighborhoods and these,
these toxic environments that these kids
are growing up and being abused and
being scared and bullied and terrible
piss poor education,
you know,
first through all the way up to high
school.
That's,
I mean,
that's really where you have to address
it.
I mean,
addressing,
adjust at the college level and giving
them the opportunity to get into college
and making it easier for them.
It doesn't negate the terrible
foundation that's been laid by their
life.
But yeah,
and I think we had this idea that
college should be for everybody.
Right.
And that's okay.
That's great.
And that's,
I think that's where the,
you know,
people like Cortez and Bernie Sanders
and others with their idea of free
tuition,
you know,
they're thinking,
okay,
well look at Europe.
You know,
there's some countries in Europe have
free tuition and hey,
it's,
you know,
it's relatively prosperous and there's
nothing wrong with that.
But at the same time,
you know,
I think we,
we don't,
we,
we don't assess the cost and the overall
efficiency of an idea sometimes.
And so we just assume and open it up,
let everybody go and somehow this is
going to work right.
To our advantage and honest got answer
is no,
you know,
I think somebody is better off
sometimes,
you know,
go into,
becoming a plumber,
you know,
maybe,
maybe not honorable living.
It's a living great.
Yeah.
To create living.
One of the happiest guys I know is my
plumber in Boise.
That guy is,
I mean,
he's got it knocked right.
He's always out for hunting season and
you know,
he'll call,
I'll say,
look,
I gotta,
I gotta Lick,
right?
I'm a if my ceilings about the cave.
And he goes,
well,
I'm going hunting and sorry,
he's just got,
he's got his own schedule.
Right.
But he's got a great job and there's
nothing wrong with that.
But I think we developed this idea.
So like homeownership,
everybody should own a home when we saw
with that took us,
right?
Yeah.
When you lower the requirements and
suddenly we're all,
you know,
it's blown up and we're fucked.
But anyway,
uh,
what do I know?
What do I,
what's the,
what do I know either,
but I see your points and I know,
I know what you're saying.
I think that one thing to disturb the
shit out of me,
his student loans,
I mean you w one of the worst ways to
prepare a kid for the futures to saddle
them down with a quarter million dollars
worth of debt by the time they graduate
from college right now.
Absolutely.
And then they get a $50,000 a year job
and they're like,
what in the,
and they're doing well with a $50,000 a
year job.
That's a great job to get out of college
and in you just look at the debt that
you have and you're like,
what the fuck is this?
How am I going to pay this shit?
Yeah.
No,
I know.
And we have sold a student's a bill.
A good yes.
And,
and,
and you know,
some of it.
Okay.
Some of it's on them,
right?
Some of it,
you know,
the older students are the ones who are
willing to take out this loan and then
suddenly they're using the money for
something else.
Okay,
fine.
There's individual responsibility.
But no,
I agree with you that there's student
loan debt is a,
is a major issue.
We occasionally that the Capitol Hill
talks about it,
but not really.
I told,
I told my daughter,
who's a fantastic person and I said,
you know,
the biggest gift you're getting is
getting out of college without any,
any debt.
That's,
you know,
so you know,
dad's not going to buy you your own
wagon here.
You got to pick out your tuition and
that's it.
That's it.
That's the best I can.
That's a gigantic headstart for kids.
I mean,
it sounds so fucked up,
but it's true.
To not be in debt is gigantic.
Look,
they're giving kids credit cards and
their frontal lobes aren't even
developed yet.
They're doing all kinds of wacky.
They're like,
wow,
I'll figure it out.
But you ain't figuring out shit.
He never figured out things up till now.
And the idea that you're going to get
magically smarter over the next months
while you owe
all this money is crazy.
Right?
You kids oldest have a phone yet for
security purposes or what is this?
What do you got here?
Jamie?
Student loan clock.
Oh my God,
what is,
I can't even figure out what that is.
One point 6 trillion try got really good
at go.
Oh,
so what is this website that people can
go to?
This college debt.com I just typed in
student loan.
Holy Shit.
Look at that.
That is an insane amount of money on a
second.
Something like that.
Is that what it is like I'm just kind of
guessing off what I'm seeing.
Yeah,
it's an insane amount of money.
So you just made that number up.
You just just stop at whatever.
No,
I don't look at credit cards.
Auto loans.
Is that the credit cards and auto loans
for us?
All of us Americans are students.
And then those,
it's all credit card debt.
When I just looked at two on another
page that had a clock at that,
it's just the same number.
It said it's not including the interest
on the federal loans.
That's crazy.
So you look at that and you think,
okay,
no wonder it's a,
it's a popular idea of saying you've got
to write down student loans,
you've got to get free tuition going on
and do all these things again.
You know,
can the country pay for it?
I don't.
I don't think so.
Should we be talking about it?
Absolutely.
She'll be looking for other alternatives
and other options.
Yeah.
But you know,
I think it's,
it's,
uh,
you know,
we're not even willing to address the
issue of social security and Medicare
and trying to deal with entitlement to
say currently exist,
which we know,
you know,
are going to bankrupt us at some point.
Right.
We know that it's not,
it's not a mystery and we can't deal
with that.
So how are we going to deal with these
other issues?
Well,
that's the question I had about a guy
trump who doesn't seem to like to pay
attention to things.
How the hell is one person supposed to
be in the director of all these various
aspects of our world?
Yeah,
no,
I,
I've heard that,
uh,
you know,
from,
uh,
what's the name of the economist,
can't remember his name,
but it went very,
very smart guy,
very smart economist who was talking
about this and saying,
this is what we expect of a president.
Think about all these things the
president has to be cognizant of and,
and,
and supposedly capable of digesting a
lot of information and making decisions
on a very number of things.
And obviously,
yeah,
you delegate and you're fine.
But it is an interesting system and it
is interesting how,
you know,
I mean right now there's a lot of people
that don't have faith in the current
president to make,
you know,
some of your basic decisions,
uh,
previous administration,
there are a lot of people that was
convinced he could understand anything,
right?
I mean,
he was capable of all of it.
So I don't think the job itself is too
big.
And I just think that the way that we,
uh,
go through the selection process has
slowly over a period of time,
you know,
gone downhill and is kind of resulted in
what we're doing right now.
Part of it's the,
the bullshit primary process,
you know,
and the way that we do the initial
selection,
there's,
you know,
there's
a lot of things I suppose.
Sure.
The fact that you have to be registered
as a Democrat or Republican to vote in
the primaries and all those things,
and then,
you know,
it was just
everything.
Like the,
the whole thing is a big mess.
But on the flip side,
here's what's crazy.
Trump doesn't seem to be aging.
Everybody.
I really think it says age is so hard.
They age so hard because they're paying
attention to everything and they have
real concern.
Well,
yeah,
that seems to be just like I've fucking
water on a duck's back.
Well,
you know,
maybe he's,
he's going to outlive with salt.
Maybe he's figured out how to avoid the
stress.
Yeah.
Oh,
you remember what prison Obama looked
like when he finally walked out office
or Bill Clinton?
I saw Bill Clinton not too long ago.
We went down a little rock.
And you saw him?
Yeah,
he was at an event that we were
relatively small dinner and chasing
pussy.
Yeah.
I'm not saying he touched me
inappropriately,
but you know,
want to know where I got my burner
phone.
Have to be a fly on the room.
Oh,
fly on the wall in a room with that.
I,
I will say this much about him.
He was,
uh,
we started talking.
I thought it was just going to go up and
shake his hand and say,
you know,
hey ms president,
good to see you.
Because I always liked the guy.
Right.
And okay.
You know,
uh,
aside from his obvious,
you know,
issue and the problem we had in terms of
his ability to,
to,
uh,
to govern and the fact that he's a,
he's a smart son of a bitch.
Um,
and he,
uh,
I just found him,
you know,
capable of the job,
right?
I just like it did with President Bush
and you know,
they were good aspects of president.
[inaudible] I thought I have a dog in
the hunt,
right?
I mean,
I'd rather see the results in the
person.
But anyway,
talking to President Clinton,
he,
uh,
we started talking and he immediately
went to a,
an old,
uh,
agency,
operation and old thing that had
happened during his time when he was
president to talk about it.
And you could tell that he,
I mean,
he had retained a tremendous amount of
information.
Right.
And we were talking and we ended up
talking for 15 minutes or so,
just kind of about this particular
incident.
And he was kind of curious and he wanted
to,
you know,
and he wanted to recount some of the
thought process that they were going
through.
And,
and I found it really interesting in the
sense that that was a,
it was a surprisingly deep conversation,
right.
For any,
and he's curious and I always thought
that was the most important quality for
anybody who gets in that job is he's,
they have to be curious,
right?
They have to be inquisitive and,
um,
you know,
on the scale of,
presidents,
where does the current president,
you know,
exist in,
in the curiosity scale?
I don't know.
But I think that's probably not his
strong suit.
So maybe that's one of the reasons why
he's not aging.
It's because he,
he's,
you know,
he's not asking that fourth or fifth
question that leads you to the point
where you go,
Huh,
that's a pretty fucked up situation now
we got to worry about that one.
So maybe it is,
you know,
water off the back and he's,
and he's,
uh,
he's figured out a way to deal with
stress.
Well,
the,
on the plus side,
he seems to be making business owners
happy.
It seems at least ones that aren't
affected by the sanctions against China
because a,
there's like steel manufacturing and a
lot of other companies that are very
upset by,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well I think it's,
it's the regulations that,
that they've done that they haven't
really touted,
uh,
in terms of deregulating,
some of the things that make us like the
previous administration,
you know,
a lot of good points,
but some bad points.
One of the bad points was a sort of,
um,
the,
uh,
hamstringing of industry through a
overregulation on everything.
Right?
And so lifting some of that on,
you know,
there's this,
you can argue whether,
you know,
you want bigger government and less
government,
but you can't argue with the fact that
it did unleashed a industry and business
more than the previous administration.
So that's a good thing.
Um,
but yeah,
look at all the other concerns.
I mean,
now we're talking about a global
slowdown because China's numbers are
looking soft.
Germany's looking soft.
What does that mean?
Everybody's worried about brexit.
So there's,
there's a lot of things for people to be
focused on,
you know.
Um,
and I worry sometimes that all we do
here in the states,
it's kind of like chasing the next shiny
ball,
a tin foil.
Cause we're all a bunch of raccoons,
right?
We have such a short attention span for
everything.
And,
uh,
anyway,
what am I saying?
I don't know.
Sorry.
Right.
Everybody's like,
well,
he was talking about attention span.
The last thing I'm going to definitely
want to talk to you about,
it's one of the things that trump
brought up recently is the JFK case and
releasing some of the files and they
wanted to redact the information that
pertained to the people that were still
alive.
Now I want to know what,
what,
I don't know what you could say,
but what do you think about the JFK
case?
Do you think that Lee Harvey Oswald
acted alone?
Um,
I can see
of all the,
of all the sort of incidents of all,
I don't mean to minimize it or minimize
it by calling it an incident,
but of all those situations,
the Kennedy assassination and Mlk,
Martin Luther King's assassination,
those are the two that I understand more
than anything else.
Why they've linkerd,
why people don't believe the shit that
they've seen and why they,
why they have concerns about it.
Uh,
Martin Luther King more than Kennedy.
I believe that there was something there
that we still don't understand in terms
of who else was responsible and who
organize that and who,
who assisted in that.
Right.
I just think of those two.
That's the one I've got bigger questions
on the Kennedy assassination.
I think that,
uh,
I think that Oswald pulled the trigger.
I think in his mind,
uh,
the reason he was doing it was for the
greater good of,
of communism and to,
uh,
boost his image with the Soviets and,
and,
uh,
w with the Cuban regime.
Um,
do I think that he had assistance?
I don't know.
I don't think so,
but I could be swayed from that with,
with better evidence than I've seen.
But,
um,
I understand why people are so dug in on
it.
Right.
Because I mean,
look,
it was a massive event,
right?
It was a massive event,
but Oswald had sufficient training.
You did not have to be a rocket
scientist to figure this out.
It was a different era and we don't
understand it in today's terms,
but when you get right in that position
and look out that window and look at the
shot that was taken and you know,
what was involved in that,
I was not,
uh,
you know,
you've shot,
you've,
uh,
this sounds terrible,
but you know,
you know,
anybody who's hunted,
has taken a more difficult shot in that.
Yeah.
Um,
so that part of it and,
and his motivation and his past ties to
the Soviets.
Do I think the Soviets were pulling the
trigger on it too?
I think the mafia,
we're pulling the trigger.
I,
I haven't seen anything that convinces
me that that was the case.
I think that Oswald felt like he was
doing it for them or he was just,
he was going to prove himself in that
regard.
But,
uh,
again,
I,
I understand why people are dug in the
mlk one,
Martin Luther King.
I just,
um,
I think that,
I don't think he acted alone.
What makes you think that?
Um,
I think that,
look,
he was a loser,
a two bit criminal,
right?
Who was constantly getting picked up for
the shift that he was doing and ending
up in jail.
But he was a mess,
right?
There was nothing clever about him.
And then leading up to the
assassination,
he cleaned up his act.
Suddenly he went from looking like a two
bit,
you know,
criminal and all to a college professor
basically.
And he had cash.
He was able to,
you know,
purchase a vehicle and he kind of went
off the grid for a while.
He went onto this drive,
right?
And sort of stayed off the grid.
And he behaved in a way that he hadn't
up until,
you know,
months before this thing took place.
And then he ended up in Europe,
you know,
and,
um,
I just,
uh,
something tells me that he had,
um,
uh,
assistance in some fashion.
I don't know who right or whatever,
but I just,
that's the one that more than than any,
any others that I've looked at,
you know,
makes me step back and go,
no,
we don't,
we don't know the whole story here.
Um,
the Kennedy thing,
I,
you know,
again,
maybe there's something out there that
we just haven't turned over a,
that's always a possibility.
But,
um,
yeah,
mlk I think is a,
is that's the one that's most
disturbing.
That's interesting.
I don't know enough about the mlk
murder.
I need to go look into that now.
Especially if you think that something
was going on.
Look at his behavior.
Um,
what the hell was his name again?
James Earl.
Ray.
James Earl Ray and I,
I've talked to his brother.
I've interviewed his brother,
um,
for what,
uh,
for a show,
a series where we did a,
uh,
kind of,
investigative look into this.
Um,
and,
um,
I,
there is,
if you,
if,
if all you do when you're,
when you're looking at this is to look
at Ray's behavior in that year leading
up to the assassination.
Um,
that's the,
that's the interesting for me,
that's the most interesting part.
I mean,
put it in context with everything he did
up until that point,
which was,
he was basically,
again,
just a two big criminal,
couldn't stay out of jail and then you
get this and you get this change in
behavior and this change in the parents
in this,
you know,
sudden ability to,
be,
uh,
something that he wasn't up until that
point,
I guess everybody can change.
But that was,
that was the most striking part for me.
Um,
there's no obvious source of income?
No,
no,
just,
uh,
just to,
you know,
just again,
just a penny.
Any criminal basically.
And,
um,
there was plenty of information.
It wasn't like he couldn't have gathered
if you say,
well,
no,
he acted on his own.
Well,
okay.
Yeah.
Was there information?
Ah,
yes.
The leading right up until the day
before there was talk about,
oh,
you know,
there were news reports showing a king
at the Lorraine Motel.
Um,
and you know,
coming in and out of the room,
you know,
that he was staying in and so it wasn't
as if,
you know,
you couldn't gather that information on
your own,
you know,
but it was again,
it was that behavior leading up to it.
And I'm not a conspiracy guy at all.
Right.
I've seen too much shit to,
you know,
to think that,
every conspiracy home water.
So,
um,
but this one,
it was disturbing in that regard.
What that's worth,
right?
Yeah.
You should look into it and we'll talk
about next time.
See what you think.
Cause I,
I'd really be interested in,
I think,
I don't think we're going to this show
that we're gonna get ready to do here.
Start filming in next month is not going
to be looking into things like that.
What is it?
What is it called?
It's got to be called black files.
They may change the number or the name
just before we go on there.
But um,
you know,
I really enjoyed the shows that I did in
the past.
American declassified with the,
they're looking into
conspiracies.
I've really enjoyed it.
I really thought it was fascinating and
I get why people feel that way.
Yeah.
Kennedy for sure when they're on the
outside.
The Kennedy wanted,
to me the bullet is the most disturbing
thing.
Yeah,
the pool would that just showed up on
Connolly's Gurney.
Oh look where we found.
We found this spot and it's not
distorted and supposedly went through
two people and shattered bone.
That magic bullet.
The magic bullet yet it's just,
I don't buy it.
And I don't think that that bullet came
from there.
That's probably the most of all things.
So cause we looked at the,
the grassy knoll issue and the
possibility of spot hitting other kids
from the other side.
Yeah.
The fuck out of here.
I've got bullet doesn't pull it drives
me crazy.
It does that there's more pieces of the
bullet fragments in connally's body.
When you look at the look at the x rays
of Conley's bodies that show bullet
fragments,
there's little pieces,
they found a little tiny pieces of metal
in his body from the bullet fragments.
Huh.
But you don't see that missing from the
bullet.
It's bullshit.
Yeah.
The bullet,
the bullet thing is,
is,
and,
and I,
you know,
again,
there's,
there's
elements of it that you look at,
but collectively I just,
you know,
and again,
maybe there's something else out there.
Maybe there is and we just haven't
uncovered it or maybe this will prompt,
you know,
some additional information.
Who knows?
But,
um,
yeah.
Anyway,
it's,
it's fascinating shit.
But uh,
I do get it because it's so,
it was such a seminal moment.
Right.
And nobody wants to think that something
that bad,
that horrific.
And that's something that could sort of
shatter the country in that fashion.
It could be done by one,
one guy,
Mike Lee Harvey Oswald or John Hinckley.
Hinckley.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
We just let him out.
Yeah.
Not for good,
right?
Not for good.
I think it was on a release program of
Fuck Outta here for life.
Get the fuck outta here forever.
I don't care how,
how well you've been behaving for 20
years.
We've been locked up in a mental,
Simon,
he shot the president.
Get the fuck Outta here.
It's like what is wrong with people?
Yeah.
I,
it's,
it's that whole idea.
He's done his time.
He's done this time.
Yeah.
He's,
he's been,
uh,
he's been rehabilitated.
And,
uh,
and that's always that argument.
Is Prison for incarceration or is it for
rehabilitation?
As for us,
for us,
shot the president.
Get in the cage.
Hey,
can I say one thing?
Yes,
please.
Oh,
we finished up,
uh,
this is sort of a,
a bump for a buddy of mine who's in
Boise,
just wrote his first book.
If anybody's out there and they're
looking for a book to read.
Um,
uh,
his name is andrew cousins and,
he's a former operator who,
you know,
knows his shit and it's his first
attempt at a fiction novel.
It's called a failed state and it's set
in Afghanistan and also here in the U S
and a couple of other places,
Turkey and Germany and elsewhere.
Uh,
interesting rate.
A lot of technical information in there.
It's a,
it's a fiction novel,
but he's dumped a lot of information in
there,
so it's clear he knows what he's talking
about,
but it's worth,
it's,
it's worth a peak.
If anybody's looking for something to
read,
look,
just you looking out for his buddy.
Yeah,
he's a good guy.
Well,
hey brother,
great to see you again.
Thank you very much.
Good luck where you show.
I appreciate that.
Come on again after it's over.
I'll do it.
Thank you everybody.
Thanks.
[inaudible].